foreign
welcome back to our Channel today we are
diving head first into the world of
networking with our networking crash
course whether you are a tech
enthusiastic student or a professional
looking to enhance your skills this
video is the perfect starting point to
unravel the mysteries of networking in
this crash course we'll break down
complex networking Concepts into simple
easy to understand terms from the basics
of how data travels through the internet
to essential networking protocols and
security measures we've got it all
covered are you ready to embark on this
networking Journey with us buckle up
because by the end of this crash course
you will be well on your way to becoming
a networking Pro and before we begin if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or a
networking professional by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with networking by learning from
the experts then try giving a show to
Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering
the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered and if you want to kick
start your career as a networking
professional in six months then try
giving a show to Simply learn skeltex
cyber security boot camp The Bootcamp
link is also mentioned in the
description box below and you can find
all the details of the boot camp by
clicking on that link now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers by opting out these boot
camp and postgraduate program courses
[Music]
you're never too old to learn anything
new whether it's an art a new language a
new sport or learning new skills to
advance your career hi I'm Phillip I'm
61 years old and last year I upskilled
with simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security after working 30 years
in the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course funny
story I want to share with you
I started off aspiring to be a DJ where
I became interested in electronic stereo
systems and how they connected and how
they operate and what made them function
and four years ago I began a journey to
understand and learn more about the
cloud on the way I develop a natural
understanding for the security needs and
began to focus my studies to understand
more about the cyber security aspect of
the cloud landscape
I worked with many companies before the
security analysts and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course I've been an adjunct
faculty member at Prince George in
college and been in many different
learning and training experiences but
the experience as a student is simply
learning something I will always cherish
the course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors I believe
in living a fulfilling life at 61. I
have still trained students through
martial arts I've been practicing
martial arts for the past 40 years and
my efforts were acknowledged by the
Eastern United States International
Martial Arts Association
where I was inducted into the Hall of
Fame for a lifetime achievement of
dedication Services martial arts I've
been many things in my life
first and foremost I've been a learner
be a learner first an introduction to
network security
network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network
with architecture comprises of tools
that protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it effective
network security strategies employ
multiple lines of defense that are
scalable and automated each defensive
layer here enforces a set of security
policies which are determined by the
administrator beforehand
this aim sets equaling the
confidentiality and accessibility of the
data and the network
the every company or organization that
handles a large amount of data has a
degree of solutions against many cyber
threats the most basic example of
network security is password protection
it has the network the user chooses
the recently network security has become
the central topic of cyber security with
many organizations involving
applications from people with skills in
this area it is crucial for both
personal and professional networks most
houses with high speed internet have one
or more wireless routers which can be
vulnerable to attacks if they are not
adequately secured
data loss theft and sabotage risk may be
decreased with the usage of a strong
network security system
the workstations are protected from
hazardous firewall thanks to network
security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network
by dividing information into various
sections encrypting these portions and
transferring them over separate Pathways
network security infrastructure offers
multiple levels of protection to thwart
man in the middle attacks preventing
situations like eavesdropping among
other harmful attacks it is becoming
increasingly difficult in today's
hyper-connected environment as more
corporate applications migrate to both
public and private talks additionally
modern applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team
Network traffic and infrastructure must
be protected in these cases since
assaults on businesses are increasing
every single day
we now understood the basics of network
security
but we need to understand how network
security works in the next section in
slightly more detail
network security revolves around two
processes authentication and
authorization
the first process which is
authentication is similar to access path
which ensure that only those who have
the right to enter a building
in other words authentication checks and
verifies that it is indeed the user
belonging to the network who is trying
to access or enter it thereby preventing
unauthorized introductions
next comes authorization
this process decides the level of access
provided to the recently authenticated
user
for example the network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network
based on the network user's role the
process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization
today's Network architecture is complex
and faces a threat environment that is
always changing and attackers that are
always trying to find and exploit
vulnerabilities
these vulnerabilities can exist in many
areas including devices data
applications users and locations
for this reason many Network Security
Management tools and applications are in
use today that address individual
threats
when it's just a few minutes of down
times can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place beforehand
neither I know a little about network
security and it's working let's cover to
the different types of network security
the fundamental tenet of network
security is the layering of protection
for massive networks and stored data
that ensure the acceptance of rules and
regulations
and so on there are three times the
first of which is physical security the
next being Technical and the third being
administrative
let's look into physical security post
this is the most basic level that
includes protecting data and network to
unauthorized Personnel from acquiring
control over the confidentiality of the
network
this include external peripherals and
routers that might be used for cable
connections the same can be achieved by
using devices like biometric systems
physical security is critical especially
for small businesses that do not have
many resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large firms
when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions
this kind fulfills two functions one is
difference against unauthorized users
the other is a defense against
manipulative actions
the last category is Administrative
this level of network security protects
user Behavior like how the permission
has been granted and how the
authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks
this level also suggests necessary
amendments that have to be done to the
infrastructure
I think there's all the basics that we
need to cover on network security in
which our next topic we're going to go
through two mediums of network security
which are the transport layer and the
application layer
so transport layer is a way to secure
information as it is carried over the
Internet with users browsing websites
emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with a
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications
the connection employs lighter symmetric
cryptography to save bandwidth and
processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
circuits poor app player security can
lead to Performance and stability issues
data theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denial
of service attacks or tdos attacks HTTP
plugs SQL injections cross-site
scripting
Etc
most organizations have an arsenal of
application layer security protections
to combat these and more such as web
application firewalls secure web Gateway
Services
Etc
now that you have the theory behind
network security has been covered in
detail let us go through some of the
tools that can be used to enforce these
network security policies
the first two to be covered in this
section is a firewall
a firewall is a type of network security
device that keeps track of incoming and
outgoing Network traffic and it decides
which traffic to allow or deny in
accordance to a set of security rules
for more than 25 years firewalls have
served as Network Security's first line
of defense they provide a barrier
between trustworthy internal protected
and regulated networks from Shady
external networks like the internet at
some points
the next two which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for sure it's an
encrypted connection between a device
and a network via the Internet
the encrypted connection is the secure
transmission of sensitive data it makes
it impossible for unauthorized parties
to eavesdrop on the traffic and enables
remote work for the user the usage of
VPN technology is common in both
corporate and personal networks next we
cover the importance of inclusion
prevention systems in network security
or IPS Frameworks
an intrusion prevention system is a
network security tool that continually
scans the network for harmful activity
and responds to it when it does occur by
reporting blocking or discarding it
can be either Hardware or software it's
more sophisticated than an inclusion
detection system or an IDs framework
which can just warn an administrator and
merely identify harmful activities while
in the case of an IPS it actually takes
against that activity
the next tool in this section and the
final one are going to be behavioral
Analytics
Behavior analytics focus more on the
statistics that are being carried over
and stored through months and years of
usage on some kind of similar pattern is
noted by the ID administrator can detect
some kind of attack the similar attacks
can be stopped and the security can be
further enhanced
another way I've covered all that we
need to know about network security the
necessary tools and different types Etc
let's go to the benefits of network
security as a whole
the first which is protection against
external threats the objective for cyber
assaults can be as varied as the
Defenders themselves
although they are typically initiated
for financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and cohort the attacks are
getting a strong cyber security
depository that considers shooting
software updates May assist Works in
identifying and responding to the abuse
techniques tools and the common entry
points
the next benefit is protection against
internal threats the human aspect
continues to be the cyber security
system's weakest link inside the risk
can originate from current or workers
third party vendors or even trusted
partners and they can be unintentional
careless or downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of threats to
go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
dangers may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive disasters
the third benefit is ilki's productivity
it's nearly impossible for employees to
function when Network and personal
devices are slowed to a crawl by viruses
and other cyber attacks during the
operation of website and for the company
to run you may significantly minimize
violations and the amount of downtime
required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls by
the scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email phishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training
another benefit is brand trust and
reputation
customer retention is one of the most
crucial elements in business development
customers today place a premium on
maintaining brand loyalty through a
strong cyber security stance since this
is the fastest way to get other
businesses back get referrals and sell
more tickets overall
additionally it helps manufacturers get
on the vendor list with bigger companies
as a part of the supply chain which is
only as strong as the three guest link
this opens possibilities for potential
future endeavors and development
ethernet
ethernet is a form of communication
Network that uses a wired medium to
connect devices for data Exchange in the
network for example land
also known as local area network
also van known as wide area network
ethernet also applies different protocol
on the data to be transmitted over the
communication Channel efficiently and
smoothly
moving on let's look into why to use
ethernet
as we now know the ethernet is a mode of
connection for multiple devices to share
and exchange data
but using this way of transmission also
has its benefit
for example
the ethernet Network provides us with a
high speed connection for sharing data
ethernet also provides the user data
with a secure channel for transmission
the data that is transmitted over the
ethernet channel is reliable and has
rarely faced in issues at the sender
site
let's move on to the next heading
now we will look into different types of
ethernet
in general the ethernet is divided into
three different types
first is
the fast ethernet this type of ethernet
operates on a twisted pair cable
with the data transmission speed of up
to 100 Mbps
first ethernet connections are used for
personal connections or use in companies
that require low internet connection
moving on we have gigabit Ethernet
this connection is used for high speed
internet connection
with a speed ranging from 1000 Mbps to 1
gbps
it is an upgraded form of fast ethernet
and the last type is Switched ethernet
this ethernet type installs network
devices such as switches or hubs so as
to improve the network transmission
the transmission range for switched
ethernet connection is around 1000 Mbps
to 10 gbps
now let's look into the working of
ethernet
ethernet Services specifically work in
the first layer of the osm model that is
known as the physical layer and the
second layer of USI module
also known as data link layer
functioning of the ethernet can be
divided into three different parts
First Step being acquiring the physical
address that is Mac address media Access
Control address of the sender and the
receiver device
then the second step is to check the
data security quality of the data and
the connection speed of the transmission
channel for efficient and smooth
transmission of data over the network
and the last step is to check Network
traffic and detect any error that occurs
in the communication Channel
to solve these issues if occur
csma protocols and other Protocols are
used
for example the csma protocol is used in
case of packet Collision in the network
channel
now let's look at a simple ethernet
model for further clarification of the
steps
but before we begin with the model
the point to be noted is
the transmission of data over the
ethernet channel is divided into two
parts
frames and packets
where packets represents a unit of data
in the network whereas frame refers to a
collection of data packets being
transmitted over the channel
and the application of ethernet Services
which includes security traffic check
and protocols being applied on the data
and that is when it reaches the receiver
end
moving on let's look into advantages and
disadvantages of using ethernet
for advantages we have cost of
installing ethernet connection is low in
comparison to other network channels
the security of the data being
transmitted over the ethernet channel is
maintained
as for disadvantages we have
it is suitable only for establishing
short distance communication Network due
to high requirement of Hardware
resources
whereas ethernet is also not suitable
for sharing real-time data and
information
let's look into some more advantages and
disadvantages
ethernet is suitable for maintaining the
data quality of the information being
transmitted
it also provides high-speed data
transmission option for the network
for disadvantages we have the network
traffic issue is a drawback of
installing ethernet cables
troubleshooting faults and issues in the
internet cable is also a Troublesome
work now let's move on to the last
heading for this topic that is ethernet
versus internet
the first difference is
connection medium
for ethernet connection physical cables
are required that means it uses wide
medium for connection
whereas in case of Internet it uses
Wireless mediums such as satellites
has a connection medium
moving on the next difference is
Network model
the ethernet is available only for a low
distance connection for example LAN
whereas internet is available for all
the network connection distances
bead Lan man or van
let's move on to the next difference
that is Network control
for ethernet
the complexity of the connection medium
is low due to the less distance it uses
and also provides much efficient
transmission of data over the
communication Channel whereas for
internet is a large collection of
networks and hence require large group
of administrator for control
the last difference between ethernet and
internet is
network security and reliability
ethernet connection is a secure network
from external interference and provides
data security
whereas in case of Internet it is an
open type of connection so it is more
prone to hacking attempts and less
secure network two major types of
network that should be considered basic
knowledge for someone starting out with
networking lands and ranks the first
variety of networks is a local area
network also known as Lang it comprises
of cables gateways switches routers and
additional parts that allow these
devices to connect to private servers
cloud services and other lands via
larger Networks the growth of
virtualization has also sped up the
creation of virtual lens which let
Network managers divide and logically
organize Network nodes without having to
make significant modifications to the
infrastructure
the computers in each department could
be conceptually linked to the same
switch in an office with many
departments be it accountancy it support
and administration
still there might be segregated to
operate separately the benefits of a
land are similar to those of any
collection of connected devices they may
access anywhere control one another
exchange files print to Shared printers
and utilize a single internal connection
to better understand this logic let us
take a sample structure
you can see the various components of a
local network connection in this picture
and now we can see three different
devices a system a laptop and a printer
if I have these few devices that need to
be connected to a single local area
network
now to identify these devices inside the
network we need to assign an identifier
to each device so this is where an IP
address can help
an IP address is a Landry sharing of
digits allocated to any device connected
to a network it utilizes Internet
Protocol as the communication medium
it's a visual equivalent of your house
or workplaces mailing address
the addresses are divided into four
sections separated by terms each
traditional Place saying numeral portion
represents an 8-bit binary integer which
can range from 0 to 255. these four
integers are expressed in normal decimal
notation and then separated by Dot
however computers work with binary
numbers meaning zeros and ones and each
number in an ipv4 address represents an
8-bit binary integer which is why none
of them can be more than 255.
the distribution of this IP addresses is
not just limited to LAN every devices is
a part of a network will have its own IP
address as assigned by the network
administrator as seen in the picture we
can now identify each device
individually by the designated IP
addresses
now the primary purpose of a network
being the ability of multiple devices to
communicate and exchange information
with each other these IP addresses serve
only half the purpose hence allotment
and identification of these addresses
need to be managed automatically and On
Demand
if the laptop shown on the left of the
screen wants to use the printer in the
network it needs to know which
particular device or more precisely
which particular IP address to
communicate
this is where a switch comes into play
it takes the role of the delegation of
commands in a particular Network
let's learn more about switches in
detail
a network switch joins devices in a
network such as computers printers
wireless access funds and allows them to
communicate with each other by
exchanging data packets they can be both
physical Hardware devices that handle
real networks or software-based virtual
devices
the vast majority of network equipment
in modern data networks are switches the
index of PCS access points automated
equipment and some iot devices via wired
connections such as card entry systems
The Limited computers and data centers
that run virtual machines or VMS as well
as the actual server and most of the
storage equipment
based on the type of switches employed
they can either differentiate between
network devices using either the IP
addresses or Mac addresses which are
separate types of addresses allotted to
each Hardware device irrespective of the
network it is connected to
now that you understand the major parts
of a local area network a major query
that may come to your mind is how can
these local networks then communicate
with other networks a rocker is employed
at the Forefront of every network setup
to facilitate communication between
foreign Networks
this router can then be used to connect
to the Internet so we can communicate
with the loved ones from the comfort of
our own homes
so let's learn a little more about
routers
the router is a physical or virtualized
Internet working equipment that receives
analyzes and transmits data packets
across computer networks router checks
and data packets destination IP address
and utilizes headers and forwarding
tables to determine the best path to
transport the packet
consider the router to be an air traffic
controller and data factors should be
airplanes flying to various airports or
networks in this case
each package like each check has a
unique destination and must be steer to
its destination as effectively as
possible
a router helps direct these data packets
to the intended IP addresses in the same
manner that the air traffic controller
ensures that flights arrive at their
destination without getting lost or
experiencing severe disruptions
a router employs an internal routing
table which is a collection of Pathways
to multiple Network destinations to
properly direct packets let's scans the
header of a packet to establish its
destination then consults a routing
table to find the most efficient way to
their destination
the packet is subsequently sent to the
next Network along the Route
a router also has an IP address which is
often called as the network Gateway
a crucial part of a networking setup is
determining whether a particular piece
of Hardware is a part of local network
or a foreign device
as you already know specific IP
addresses exist for each device in a
network be it a local or wide area
network all these IP addresses must
belong to a particular range of
addresses which are often known as the
subnet or sub Network and which help
determine the overall range of a local
area network
for example the IP addresses that can be
seen on the screen right now belong to a
subnet that is 255.255.0.0
the first two flags did not fix values
that must be present in every single IP
address of every single device in this
particular Network
in our case the 192.168 is the
consistent factor in every single IP
address shown on the screen
this implies that if the devices can
connect to a piece of equipment with an
IP address and it starts from 192.168
that device will most likely be in the
same local area network
the last two places are the three ranges
in this example which means they can be
any number less than 255 for the help in
the router and switch differentiate
between multiple IP addresses in the
network
with that being said we can now take a
look at how wide area networks work
a wide area network or a van is in its
most basic form a collection of local
area networks for any other networks
that interact with one another
why Data Network is essentially a
network of networks with internet
serving as the world's biggest one
however when a router communicates with
devices outside a local network it tends
to mask the internally allocated IP
addresses and uses a single public IP
address for all the devices
this process is called Network address
translation or Nat IP allocation
a network address translation is a
method of translating one IP address to
another while these packets are in
transit through a router this improves
security and reduces the number of IP
addresses required by a company
once the router receives some particular
information that must be transmitted to
a local device in the network it checks
the internal routing tables to determine
the correct internal IP address and the
current destination to send the external
leadership data to
but let's say a device on external
network or a wide area network wants to
communicate it directly with a device
from the local network
this cannot be allowed since this can be
a very big security risk for devices in
a secure environment
all of this M3 and exit rule creation
and handling can be taken care of by a
firewall
a firewall is a type of network security
device that analyzes the incoming and
outgoing networking traffic and allows
or denies data packets depending on a
set of security rules
its objective is to provide a barrier
between your local network and external
traffic such as the internet
the most common sort of firewall which
are packed at filtering firewalls check
packets and prevent them from getting
through if they do not maintain
established security rules
this sort of firewall examines the
package destination and Source IP
addresses if the packet fits an allowed
rule on the firewall they are permitted
to access the network
but let's say we as users want to allow
external requests to reach individual
computers or devices on our local
network
there are two ways to facilitate this
Behavior the first way to go through
this step is by using a DMZ which stands
for a demilitarized zone
instead of communicating directly with
the local network device the external
data is sent to the router instead
the router will have created a DMC sub
network with only those devices added to
it that's required under external
information to reach them on all
once the data is received by the router
it passes it on to the dng subnet and
subsequently to all the devices which
are a part of that submit
however since the external data can
reach devices in a network without any
firewall checks if they are part of the
DMC subnet the security risk associated
with this method are very large compared
to the second variant which is port
forward
ing is a method of granting external
devices access to computers on private
networks it accomplishes this by
translating an external IP address and
port to an internal IP address and port
all the devices talk to each other and
the network Gateway using the IP
addresses and specific ports for example
the TCP IP protocol basic internet usage
uses Port 80 on every Network
similarly we can create additional file
or rules to open up certain ports for
external devices to communicate with if
the designated ports are open during
communication the firewall will allow
the external network device or server to
communicate directly with the local
network device without any hindrance
it's all you really need to know for now
about the basics of networking then
let's begin with the first setting what
is Network topology
it is referred to as an arrangement a
multiple system and network devices
interconnected to each other through a
physical medium or logical channels
the term Network topology is combination
of two individual Network concept
first is the network part
which represents the devices or systems
that are also known as nodes
which is connected and how to change the
data within the network then the other
part is topology which represents the
connection medium between different
network devices and governs the data
flow between them moving on let's talk
about why do we apply the concept of
network topology for the first point it
allows the users to understand the
overall model of the network along with
the number of devices installed and
their positions in the network which
provide ease of installation of security
measures and network and helps in case
of troubleshooting cases then for the
next reason applying Network topology
helps the user to understand the
communication relationship among the
different devices and through a
connection medium
this in turn helps the network
professionals to set up an optimal
Network unit for the user
next in the list we have different types
of topologies used in networking
first is the bus topology then we have
ring topology then start topology then
tree topology and in the end mesh
topology but to understand the concept
of topology let's start by point to
point topology this is simpler form of
topology connection which consists of
two nodes connected through a connection
medium like a network cable
the nodes at the two ends of the cable
shares data information between them
where the data sharing part represents
the network and the cable connection is
the topology part
with this we have understanding of
network topology then let's begin with
complex types of tech connections first
is the bus topology in this topology the
connection channel is a single cable
known as the network backbone through
which all the other nodes are connected
to
in this network setting the data packets
sent by the nodes are provided with the
receiver address to avoid transmission
errors the data in this topology can
travel from any endpoint where they are
termed as terminate points advantages of
bus topology it is easy to set up due to
that simple configuration settings
this setting is also cost effective as
it requires only a network cable for the
connection
in the case of Krishna the whole network
remains unaffected as it does not have
any direct connection to the other node
let's take a look at disadvantages of
bus topology
in case of troubleshooting we require
the use of special equipment to detect
The Fault in the network in the case of
multiple data transmission the packet
Collision is the frequent occurrence
damaging the transmitted message data
due to the unavailability of network
devices such as switches repeaters Etc
the loss of data over long distances
communication is quite High
then ring topology as the name suggests
the node in the network are connected in
a circular pattern similar to a ring
the data transmitter in this connection
is always in the clockwise Direction
the topology does not have any
termination point due to its ring
structure the method of data
transmission is used is known as token
passing which involves sending a token
along with the data packet to which each
of the node matches to identify the
destination node using the destination
address in the token
next advantages of ring topology the
trash node can be easily removed from
the network
the configuration settings are not
complex for setup and materials are
easily accessible
the cost of installation is low as no
extra Network device are required to the
connection
moving on we have disadvantages of Link
topology in the case of a node crash the
whole system is affected and is known
accessible due to the direct connection
of each node the transfer of data is
slow due to the Token passing method in
the network
difficulty in the trouble shorting fault
in the connection leads to the crash of
the whole network now let's talk about
start apology in this topology the
networks are connected to each other
through the central Hub which can be a
computer or a server the central unit in
the connection is also known as the
server and the nodes are known as the
clients any connection between the nodes
has to be through the server and is one
of the most popular topology connection
next advantages of start apology in case
of a node crash the network as a whole
remains unaffected as each node is
connected to the server of a connection
the hardware requirements are easily
available and of low cost
troubleshooting is easy through the use
of central Hub to identify the faulty
node disadvantages in case of a server
failure the whole network is shut down
as all nodes are interconnected through
the server the connection configuration
is complex due to the pattern of the
typology next up free topology this
topology is a combination of tar and bus
topology the node Connection in the
topology follows hierarchical pattern
with the topmost node as a root and the
branching node as the child node the
sharing of data is from the root node to
the child node pattern
next up advantages of tree installation
of a new network group is easy due to
the root child configuration of the
network
in case of a node fault or trash the
whole network is not affected by the
error this makes it easier to
troubleshoot the issue
next up disadvantages in case of a
server crash in any of the star
connection group the whole network is
affected due to the complex setting of
The topology installing security points
is difficult in the network
configuring and troubleshooting internal
issues is quite complex due to this
topology next up match topology
as the name suggests this topology is a
connection of interconnected system
connected to each other in no particular
order
no installation of network devices such
as switch or hubs this topology pattern
can be divided into two forms first is
full match topology in this connection
all the nodes are connected to each
other in the network then we have
partial mesh topology where all of the
nodes are connected to each other
available in the network let's talk
about the advantages of mesh topology in
case of node damage the whole network
does not suffer from the fault due to
the interconnected patterns of the
connection the transmission of data is
very high in the network
next up disadvantages the cost of
installation is high due to the
requirement of multiple cables and nodes
for the network to function efficiently
the management of the network becomes
complex due to the large number of
interconnections in the network due to
the absence of repeater or a switch the
data signal loss during the transmission
is very high now let's take a look at
how to choose best topology for a
network configuration first of course
the installation cost is one of the
biggest factor that affects the type of
topology configuration we choose from
our Network as the cost of installing
cables routers such as and other network
connections is slow then we have easy
installation installing the hardware
devices efficiently and precisely is
also one of the factors that affect our
choice of network topology moving on we
have flexibility the ability of the
topology to include new network nodes
after installation and ease of
troubleshooting refers to the
flexibility of topology in the hand we
have reliable security it is important
that the Tuple installed allows us to
introduce proper security point in the
network and leading the fewer crash
cases by referring the above factors we
can decide the best topology of for our
Network
to better understand the USM model let's
take a look at a scenario
assuming we have two different systems
with different operating system
installed in them
and there is a communication Channel
between them over which the data is
shared
but sometimes during transmission of
data it faces some problems
these errors often arise due to the
different operating system installed in
the system or due to a network problem
during a transmission
but to overcome such situations
The OSI model structure is used
OSI model structure we can make the
transmission of data over the
communication Channel error free
let's take a look at the definition for
the OSI model
the osm model stands for Open System
interconnection model or a specifically
designed set of protocols and standards
that governs the modeling and conversion
of the data for proper transmission over
the network channels
the osm model is based on the layer
structure where it consists of seven
different layers where each layer has
different set of protocols that are to
be applied on the data during the
transmission over the network channel
let's take a look at the different
layers of the OSI model
the osm model consists of seven
different layers which perform specific
functions and apply different protocols
at different layers to maintain the
quality and prevent the data from
getting corrupted when it is transmitted
over the communication Channel
let's take a look at each of them the
first layer is known as the application
layer which is a topmost layer then we
have the presentation layer
session layer transport layer
Network layer data link layer and
physical layer which is the last layer
of the OSI model
the upper four layers in the OSI model
represents the host layers that is they
interact with the application related
issues when the data is transmitted over
the communication Channel
whereas the lower layers are termed as
networkless
they specifically deal with the
transmission related steps for the data
over the network channel
let's take a look about some information
in regards to the layers
now let's take a look at the function
and the data format that is handled by
each of the layers during the
transmission of data
the first layer is the application layer
which interacts as a Gateway for the
host data and network applications and
handles the data format
then we have the presentation layer
which handles the initial step towards
the conversation of data for transfer it
also handles the data format
then we have the session layer session
layer establishes a connection between
the network devices for the data
transfer
then we have the transport layer which
oversees the data that is transferred
without any error and is in the same
pattern needed by the destination system
the data format handled by this layer is
segment format
next we have the network layer which
determines the part for the data
transfer it handles packet related data
then we have the data link layer which
performs the task of connecting the
physical nodes for the transfer of data
it handles Frame data
and in the end we have the physical
layer which is used to transfer the raw
bits that is in terms of ones and zeros
over the physical mode
now that we are clear about different
layers that are present in the USM model
and some information regarding them
let's take a look at each of the layers
in detail
we'll start with top to bottom that is
the application layer will be the layer
that we'll be starting with
let's take a look
the topmost layer in the osm model is
the application layer which acts as an
interface between the user and the
applications that are being accessed
which can be Internet Explorer Chrome or
any email client
it also handles different protocols that
are needed for the data transmission
over the network channel which can be
given as
hypertext transfer protocol the HTTP
protocol and the SMTP protocol which is
the simple mail transfer protocols
now let's move on to the next layer the
next layer is known as the presentation
layer
the presentation layer is responsible
for performing conversion tasks over the
data that is received from the
application layer
the conversion of data is done in
accordance to the required format
it also performs encryption over the
converted data so as to prevent it from
getting hacked by cyber criminals or
hackers
the compression of the encrypted data is
also performed by the presentation layer
so that it can be passed on to the
session layer
the next layer in the osm model is known
as the session layer
in this layer the communication Channel
between two different devices is
established
the network devices are individually
known as session
the data that is transferred is to be
done over these session channels
that layer that is the session layer
establishes and terminates these
sessions in case of an error or some
other unforeseen event
this layer is also responsible for
authentication checks regarding the data
that is mean transferred and also
provides data recovery options in case
an error occurs over the communication
Channel some model list let's take up a
question
the question is what is the mean action
that takes place at the presentation
layer
and the options are
First Option data segmentation second
option encryption of data third option
framing of data and the fourth option
bit conversion of data
you can provide your answers in the
comment section below let's move on to
the next layer
the next layer in the osm model is known
as the transport layer
the main task performed by this layer is
to break the data that is received from
the session layer into different
segments
these segments comprises of protocols
which are UDP protocol and TCP protocol
along with the data that is segmented
from the received data
then the segmented data along with the
udpr and TCP identification it
transferred over to the transmission
Channel where then it's further
transferred to the network devices that
requested for the data
this layer also performs a very crucial
part which is the flow control
let's understand flow control over the
network channel through a small example
in this example the server has a
capacity to send 50 Mbps of data at once
whereas the receiver site has a capacity
for 10 Mbps
when the data is transferred from the
server to the client it transfers 50
Mbps
but it is impossible to transfer all
this data at once due to the lower
capacity on the client side
which is why the flow control changes is
required which is provided to the server
side by the transport layer
now let's move on to the network layer
which is the third layer from the bottom
in the osm model
this layer is responsible for breaking
down the segments into Data packets
by adding IP address to them that it
received from the transport layer
these data packets are then further
transmitted over to the best possible
route to the destination system which
are governed by the internet protocols
including IP and IPv6 protocols
for example if we have a data that is to
be transferred to the network device 2
bit choose the best option that is the
route to be transferred over to that
Network device
now let's move on to the next layer in
the OSI model which is a data link layer
this layer is responsible for
maintaining and terminating the
established connection between the
devices over the network
the MAC address in this layer is added
to the data packets which are
collectively known as data frames
these data frames are then further
transmitted over to the physical Network
these are divided into two different sub
layers
medium access control that is Mac which
controls the established connection
device and the second sub-layer is
logical link control layer LLC which
identifies the address and provide flow
control for the data
this data frame has earlier told is
transferred over to the physical tab
now let's take a look at another
question to brush up whatever we learned
so far
the question is
which layer includes the max sub layer
in the OSI model Option 1 application
layer option 2 session layer option 3
data link lab option 4 transport layer
you can give your answers in the comment
section below
let's move on to the last layer in the
osm model which is a physical layer
this layer is responsible and provides
the physical medium over which the data
frame is transferred
but the transfer data is converted into
bits before it's transferred
the transmission of data is covered by
different protocols that are embedded in
the physical layer
the transmission of ones and zeros
format data is done it also responsible
for maintaining the data quality by
applying different necessary protocols
and maintaining the bit rate throughout
the transfer of data whether it be wide
medium or wireless media firstly we'll
understand what exactly is the model the
TCP model is a method of sharing data
and information over the communication
Channel
where the data has to go through each of
the four layer structure of the network
model
where it also performs tasks such as
remodeling of data efficient
transmission and air related issues
each layer has dedicated protocols that
they enact on the transmission data
now let's continue with the protocols
that are used in the TCP model
to understand the protocols that are
used in the TCP model we'll compare it
with the OSI model and if you want to
know more about the OSI model you can
visit a video on the simply learn
Channel
let's begin
the topmost three layers of the OSI
model which are application layer
presentation layer and session layer
collectively refers to the application
layer in the tcbip model where they use
protocols such as FTP file transfer
protocol HTTP hypertext transfer
protocol Tel length and SMTP which is
simple mail transfer protocol
then we have the transport layer from
OSI model which refers to the transport
layer in the TCP model
where they apply protocol such as TCP
transmission control protocol and UDP
user datagram protocol
moving on we have Network layer from the
osm model which refers to the internet
layer in the TCP model
which apply a protocol such as IP
Internet Protocol
icmp internet control message protocol
and arp
address resolution protocol
then we have data link layer and
physical layer from the USM model which
refer to the network access layer in the
TCP model
this layer doesn't exactly apply any
protocol but are connected through
physical medium which includes ethernet
Wi-Fi and cables
now that we are completed with the
protocols regarding TCP model let's take
a look at the layers in detail
the tcpip network model consists of
different layers where the original
model consists of four different layers
which are application layer transport
layer internet layer and network access
layer then we have the updated model
which consists of layer application
layer transport layer internet layer
data link layer and physical layer
let's take a look at the layers in
detail
the first layer that we are going to
know about is the application layer
application layer this layer acts as an
interface between the application and
programs that require the TCP model for
communication
including tasks performed by the layer
such as data representation for the
software application that are executed
by the user and then forward it to the
transport layer
the protocol supplied by these layers
are
HTTP hypertext transfer protocol which
is used to access information available
on the internet then we have SMTP simple
mail transfer protocol which is used to
access email related tasks
moving forward we have the transport
layer this layer is responsible for
establishing connection between the
sender and the receiver device
this layer performed the task of
dividing the data from the application
layer into packets
where they are used to create sequences
which are then transferred over to the
destination device it also performs the
task of maintaining the data that is to
be transmitted without error and
controls the data flow rate
the protocols that are applied in the
transport layer are
TCP transmission control protocol which
is responsible for transmission of
segments over the communication Channel
then we have UDP user datagram protocol
which is responsible for identifying
error in the data that is to be
transmitted over the communication
Channel
moving forward the next layer is the
internet layer
this layer is responsible for the
transmission of data over the network
channel that is they provide a proper
route for the packets to be transferred
over the communication Channel
the protocols that are applied by this
internet layer are IP protocol which is
the Internet Protocol
this protocol assigns a unique address
to a physical system
so that it can be identified on the
internet
then we have arp
address resolution protocol
this protocol is used to find the
physical address of the system using the
Internet Protocol address
in the end we have the network access
layer this layer is a combination of
data link layer and physical layer from
the USM model
where it is responsible for maintaining
the task of sending and receiving data
in Roberts
the raw bits are transferred from the
sender side to the receiver side in the
format of binary digit which are zeros
and ones
let's move on with the advantages of
using the TCP model
the TCP model assigns an IP address to
each of the system that is available on
the network channel so that they can be
identified on the internet
then they are also responsible for
enacting different protocols on the data
that is to be transmitted over the
communication channel the TCP model also
enables the user and the system to
access different format of data over the
communication Channel
now let's take a look at the last topic
for this session which is the osm model
versus a TCP model
on comparing both of the network models
we get
The OSI model consists of seven
different layers whereas the TCP model
comprises of four different layers
The OSI model has separate session layer
presentation layer whereas the TCP model
comprises of a single application layer
the transport layer in the USM model
provides packet delivery protocols but
in the TCP model transport layer does
not provide any such protocols
the osm model is implemented during
network communication
but in case of TCP model it is used as a
reference model for the network channel
if you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or a
networking professional by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with networking by learning from
the experts then try giving a show to
Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering
the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered introduction to network
protocol a network protocol is like a
set of rules that govern how devices in
a network communicate with each other
these rules are like instructions that
specify how data should be sent received
and understood by the devices Network
Protocols are formalized requirements
and plans that consist of rules and
procedures that describe how devices
should interact with each other over a
network they provide a communication
system to exchange information using
various physical means such as cables or
wireless connections just like humans
follow certain protocols when they
interact with each other natural
protocols Define a specific steps and
guidelines for devices to follow these
rules ensure that information is sent
and received correctly and that all
devices involved understand each other
in essence Network Protocols are a way
for devices to speak the same language
and follow a common set of guidelines so
that they can successfully share
information and work together
effectively now let's understand the
need of network protocols all right so
let me explain this to you in simple
terms Network Protocols are like
guidelines that devices follow when they
communicate with each other over a
network these Protocols are needed for
several reasons firstly Network
protocols ensure that devices understand
each other imagine if you and your
friend were speaking different languages
and had no way to understand each other
communication would be impossible
similarly devices from different
manufacturers and with different
functions need a Common Language or
protocol to understand each other's
signals and data secondly Network
protocols ensure that data is
transmitted reliably when you send a
message or a browser a website you want
to make sure that the information
reaches its destination accurately and
without errors Network protocols help in
breaking down data into smaller packets
sending them across the network and
reassembling them correctly at the
receiving end thirdly Network protocols
provide security they include measures
to protect data from unauthorized access
and ensure that sensitive information
remains confidential this is
particularly important when you make
online transactions or share personal
information over the Internet lastly
Network protocols allow for
interoperability this means that devices
from different manufacturers and with
different functions can work together
seamlessly for example your computer can
connect to a printer and your smartphone
can access a Wi-Fi network because they
follow the same protocols so these were
some of the needs of network protocols
now before understanding the types of
network protocols we must to understand
about ethernet so ethernet is a type of
network protocol that helps devices
connect and communicate with each other
in a local area network Lan it is like a
highway that allows data to travel
between devices such as computers
printers and routers ethernet uses a set
of rules and procedures to transmit data
in the form of packets these packets are
like small packages of information that
are sent from one device to another
ethernet ensures that these packets are
delivered to the right destination and
in the correct order think of ethernet
as the road system that connects all the
devices in our Network it ensures that
data can flow smoothly between devices
enabling them to share information and
work together efficiently now let's have
a look at the types of network protocols
here we will cover some of the types of
network protocols we'll start with the
first one which is TCP that is
transmission control protocol TCP is a
network protocol that ensures reliable
and order delivery of data between
devices it breaks down data into smaller
packets sends them across the network
and ensures that they are reassembled
correctly to the receiving end TCP also
handles error detection and
re-transmission if any packets are lost
or corrupted during transmission so this
was about TCP or transmission control
protocol now second is IP that is
Internet Protocol IP is another Network
protocol that handles the addressing and
routing of packets across the internet
it assigns unique IB addresses to
devices and determines how data is sent
from The Source device to the
destination device IP ensures that the
data packets reach the right destination
by routing them through various network
devices like routers third is UDP or
user datagram protocol you UDP is a
network protocol that provides a faster
but less reliable method of data
transmission compared to TCP it does not
establish a connection or guarantee
packet delivery or order
UDP is commonly used for time sensitive
applications like video streaming or
online gaming where a small amount of
data loss is acceptable next is pop that
is post office protocol pop is a network
protocol used for retrieving emails from
a mail server to a client device it
allows users to download emails from the
server onto their device and manage them
locally pup is typically used by email
clients like Outlook or Thunderbird next
we have is SMTP or simple mail transfer
protocol SMTP is a network protocol used
for sending emails from a client device
to a mail server it handles the
transmission of email messages and
ensure that they are delivered to the
appropriate recipients mail server SMTP
is responsible for the reliable transfer
of email across different mail Reserves
so this was about simple make transfer
protocol now let's understand the sixth
one which is file transfer protocol or
FTP FTP is a network protocol used for
transferring files between devices over
a network it provides a standard method
for uploading and downloading files to
and from a remote server FTP allows
users to navigate directories transfer
files and manage file permissions now
coming to the next which is hypertext
transfer protocol secure that is https
HTTP is a secure version of HTTP that
provides encryption and authentication
it ensures that the data transmitted
between a web browser and a web server
is encrypted and protected from
unauthorized access http
s is commonly used for secure online
transactions sensitive data transfers
and protecting users privacy so these
were some of the types of network
protocols so basically Network protocols
play a crucial role in enabling
communication and data transfer across
various computer networks we have
explored several types of network
protocols each serving specific purpose
and operating at different layers of
networking models ip4 addresses
foreign
the first version of an IP address to be
developed was based on 32-bit binary
format that counts roughly around 2 to
the power 32 bits of total IP addresses
in ipv4 format
which was sufficient at the initial
phase of network requirement but is
somewhat lacking according to the
current advancement in the Network
Technology
the addresses in this IP ranges from 0
to 225 in terms of zeros and months
with 4 octets where each of them is
separated by a period
this is an example for an ipv4 IP
address
where the first three parts represent
the network ID
and the last part represents the host ID
using the ipv4 address as I are
reference we can identify ipv4 addresses
from my pv6 addresses
now let's move on to the next topic that
is ipclasses
IP classes are designed to allow easy
and efficient assignment of IP addresses
to a network
depending on class size we have five
different IP classes in a network that
are named as a b c and d
for the first part we have class A
that accommodates network with a large
number of network hosts where the first
bit in the octet is always zero with
number value ranging from 0 to 127.
then we have class P
which can fulfill the requirement for a
moderate number of network host
the lead bit is 1 and 0. and network ID
ranges from 128 to 191.
then we have class C which can allocate
an IP address for Low number of network
host where the first three bits of the
network ID is one one and zero ranging
from 192 to 223
so the above three classes that is Class
A B and C
we can easily identify and assign
addresses to a network host
moving on behalf class D
where it is used for multicasting
that means it is used to send multiple
signals at the same time from a single
host
for example using video streaming
where the lead bit is one one and zero
with network ID ranges from 224 to 239
and then we have class E where the IP
bits for this is reserved for research
purpose only
where the IP addresses ranges from 240
to 255.
moving on let's take a look at some of
the features for ipv4 version addresses
where the first is
the memory required for storing ipv4
version addresses in a system is very
low
then we have ipp4 version addresses
apply connectionless protocol for
sharing data and providing the best
effort in delivery
moving on we have stacking option for
ipv4 addresses that means in ipv4
version it allows to create a multiple
network over a single host which allows
different hosts to connect to it
moving on we have
ipv4 version addresses being the
earliest IP design are applicable to
most of the network devices and system
for connecting to the internet so it is
supported by many devices
then we have IPv6 addresses let's take a
look
with the increase in the need for an IP
address the ipv4 version addresses are
somewhat unable to complete the
requirements of the network host
so the need for ipv4 version Eros which
is based on 128-bit address size which
is sufficient for a very long time
that is approximately 320 under zillion
IP addresses in version 6.
this type of ipv version is designed of
four hexadecimal digit and 8 sets with
each block containing 16 bits separated
by a colon
moving on let's take a look at some of
the features for IPv6 version addresses
where the first is
ipv version 6 addresses provides an
integrated security protocol for the
network that is Internet Protocol
security
ipsec
then we have it allows its application
to extend in various Services according
to the need of the network
it also allows address configuration
pretty stateful that uses DHCP server
for network settings and stateless that
applies Auto configuration settings
IPv6 addresses also allows some methods
to convert ipv4 addresses to IPv6
addresses
which is according to the requirement of
the host or the network
moving on let's take a look at the
differences between ipv4 version
addresses and IPv6 version addresses
this heading would allow us to choose a
best IP address that we can decide for a
network
let's take a look at the first
difference that is address and
performance
in accordance to the address size ibv4
version is composed of 32-bit address
length and is the fourth version of the
Internet Protocol
for ibv6 we have the address size is 128
bit long and there's a latest version of
the Internet Protocol
the second difference is on the basis of
address field type
IPv6 addresses are based on numeric data
with four Fields each separated by a
period
whereas for IPv6 addresses are based on
alphanumeric type data with eight Fields
each separated by a column
the next difference is based on address
configuration
in ipv4 version addresses a manual
setting for the network is required
along with the dhcb configuration
settings
whereas in case of IPv6 version
addresses the network setting is based
in accordance to the systems requirement
and it also supports Auto configuration
setting for the system
moving on we have the number of artists
in each IP
in case of ipv4 the total number of
addresses are nearly 4 billion addresses
whereas in case of ipe6 version we have
320 under zillion addresses
now let's take up a quiz to understand
what we did so far and the question is
identify the correct form of ipv4
version address in the given options
and the options are
you can give your answers in the comment
section below
let's move on to the next difference
that is address security and functioning
ipv4 version addresses do not provide
any security function for the network
whereas in case of IV 6 addresses
integrated Internet Security protocol
that is ipsec it's responsible for the
security of the network
the next difference is
encryption and authentication settings
ipv4 version does not provide any
encryption or authentication services
for the network
IPv6 addresses do provide mandatory
encryption and authentication services
for its addresses
moving on behalf address routing and
performance
ipv4 version follows routing protocol
that has rip for network configuration
and is preferred over IPv6 version
and in case of IPv6 it does not follow
any routing protocols and it uses static
routes for Network functioning
now that we have completed with the
differences between IPv6 and ipv4 we can
easily identify the IP address we want
to choose for our Network
let's take a look at Network sniffing
to access the network related
information between devices to gain
profit or use the hack data for illegal
purpose is known as Network sniffing
this is a process where a hacker or
measures programmer spy into the network
devices of our system
they can access different websites that
we visit often or see our Network habits
let's take a look at different tools
that are suitable for sniffing purpose
Network sniffing tools are softwares
that are available on the internet that
can be used to sniff into the network
let's take a look at some of the famous
Network Tools first one is Avic this is
a networking sniffing tool which has
specialization in intelligent analysis
for Network packets
next is Wireshark this software tool is
best to look into protocol related data
packets that are often transmitted over
the network
and lastly we have solar wind Network
packet sniffer
where the performance of this sniffing
tool is best where the Performance
Management is to be looked into
let's take a look at the Wireshark
sniffing tool this is an open source
Network snapping software which is
specifically designed to attack data
packets during a transmission over the
network this type of software uses
different color combinations to
represent different packets and
protocols let's take a look at some of
the uses for the sniffing software
the first uses it is used to analyze
Network packets
whereas it can also be used to
troubleshoot different network issues
which are often used by different
Engineers to test whether the software
or a network device is acceptable to an
attack
and lastly it is also used to check
malicious and hacking possibilities on
the network now that we are completed
with the briefing for the software that
is known as Wireshark let's take a look
at the actual demo how exactly Network
sniffing is done you can directly access
the Wireshark software website
where you can find the download option
and download the most suitable
version for your laptop or computer
device
after downloading the software when you
install it
you will get something like this
as we can see these connections are the
connections that are connected to my
laptop right now
and the difference in the graph that we
can see over here represent the traffic
on the network that is present
to much better understand what exactly
is going on the network we can access
one of them let's access the Wi-Fi
network on my laptop
after accessing the network we can see
some packet settings like this
these represents the packet transaction
that has been made on my network through
the internet
and this is how a hacker or a cyber
criminal knows how exactly we use a
network services
this part of the Wireshark represents
different detailed information about the
transaction that has been made
and the last section represents some raw
data or Garbage data
but how exactly a hacker use all this
jumble data and hack into a system
well to clarify this there's an option
that can be used that is known as diff
display filter on the Wireshark software
if you want to search for a specific
protocol for example TCP we can write
TCP in the search filter and search
and now as we can see
we only get the protocols that are
related to TCP
this is how we can differentiate
different protocols and access some of
them to gain knowledge about what
exactly is going on with the network
let's try accessing some other protocol
now
for example
DNS
and as we can see
only the protocol and the data packet
that is related to DNS protocol is
visible to us
to further enhance the display filter
let's try accessing a
different page on the web browser for
example
simplylearn.com
when we access a simply learned website
we can see the professional courses that
are available but let's take a look at
the changes that has been made on the
Wireshark
to know this let's write
TCP and a keyword included contains
and one more thing to include over Eis
during the display filter if you write
something that is related to the
software it will represent in a green
color like this but if you write some
error related keywords like this it will
represent in the red
let's continue with the search setting
including the contains keyword and
writing
simply learn
and entering now as we can see these two
related data packets represent the
simply learned website that we access
just now where the source destination IP
address represent
my system address whereas the
destination that is
13.224.21.74 represent the simply learns
IP address let's take a look
and in the garbage area or the raw data
we can take a look simply learn website
to see some more details regarding the
same
you can access the transport layer
security
and the transmission control protocol
where we can see the source Port the
destination Port which is always 443.
as well as
the flag
and the timestamp for the same
this is how hackers get the data about a
network settings but if we want to
search for more data related to Simply
learn website that we visited just now
they send another filter that we can use
for example
using IP Dot addr
space equal equal and writing the IP
address for the website simply learn
that is
13.224
.21.74 and when we press enter we get
all the related data for the simply
learn website
and this is how we can see the related
data
to much further enhance our display
settings let's try in another example
access your internet browser
and access some other website for
example
dot for example the State University
and access the alawat State University
and some other are net for example the
university State PDF
let's see the changes in our Wireshark
settings
and try using http
when we write this we get the data that
is related to the HTTP but what is the
use for the same
when you access this and right click on
the same and choose the option follow
and HTTP stream
and over here we can take a look at the
post that is the website that we just
visited
now imagine if we were a hacker and we
knew all this we can access any website
that a user visited
and we can hack into his system through
the website
guys but the point that has to be noted
over ERS if we use the network sniffing
tool why shark or some other tool that
is available on the internet for
research purpose or experimental use
that's fine but we shouldn't use all
these softwares for any malicious
activity because that is illegal
now
some of the options that we can see are
the Red Box this action is used if you
want to stop the traffic connection that
means if we press this option
and clear this and press enter
this shows
that the network settings has stopped
receiving any traffic that is available
on the network but if we want to access
them again
we can choose this Bluefin option
continue without saving
and the software against
start recording the websites or the data
packets that are available on the
network
now let's take a look at an example as
we all know we often visit different
websites and there are some cases we
often see when the Chrome represent a
non-secure option
that represents that the website is
unprotected against network attack
for example we can access our
experimental website
this is a website that allows us to
access the non-secure part of a website
if we write for username as
admin1213 and for password as
simply learn
and login
as this is an experimental website it
says it's sorry and the login has failed
let's see the changes in a Wireshark
software
now as we already did earlier if you
want to access a specific website we
should write TCP
contains and the keyword of the website
that was
admin
through this we can see this was the
website that we visited just now
but if we want to access the actual
important data that was the password
that we typed
we can use this option
and over here we can see the simply
learn
which was encrypted earlier in the
website
this is how a hacker or a cyborg
criminal use different sniffing
softwares and gain data about different
users
and with this we have reached the end of
the session what is subnetting
the process of subnetting is to divide
the network into smaller Network paths
this allows the system to have better
connectivity in the system it also
increases the security measures for the
network against hacking attempts and
also maintains an efficient flow of
network traffic
the smaller divided units of the network
are known as sub Networks
taking an example of an IP address with
Slash 24 representing the subnet mask
can be divided into two sub-networks or
slash 25 subnet mask which can further
be divided into smaller sub Networks
now that we understand what is
subnetting let's move on to class
addresses and subnet mask
firstly let's begin with class addresses
to better understand the subnetting
process we need some information
regarding different classes used in IP
address
where the first class is Class A with a
range of 0 to 127 Network width AS Slash
8.
then we have class B with a range of
120a to 191
with network bits as 16. and lastly we
have class C with network range of 192
to 223 with network bits as 24.
the network bits representing each class
are very important when making subnets
of a particular IP address
let's see how they do so
for this we'll be representing each
class in binary format for class A we
have 1 for 8 Bits
for class B 16 bits and Class C 24 bits
moving on we will see what exactly is
the subnet mask
to better Define the sub networks in the
system we require the use of a subnet
mask that is the subnet mask is a way to
differentiate between the portion of an
IP address that represents the network
address ID and the host network ID
in this let's see the default subnet
mask for each of the class
for class A we have
255.0.0.0 for class B we have
255.255.0.0
whereas for Class C we have
255.255.255.0
to better understand this let's take a
look at the classes individually
the network ID part is the one that
represents the binary digit 1 whereas
host ID represents binary digit 0.
that means for class A we have 8 Bits at
its network ID and the remaining bits as
host ID
by looking at the host ID we can see
that the network addresses that are
available for the host is the largest in
the class A
whereas for class pvm 16 bits for
network ID and the remaining for host ID
where we can see the remaining part for
the host ID is lesser than Class A that
means Class B can assign Network IDs for
a medium level company
and lastly for Class C we have 24 bits
as network ID and the remaining for host
ID from this we can see that the host ID
used for Class C is the lowest that
means only smaller division companies
can use Class C
moving on let's take a look at the
characteristics of the subnetting
process
first is the network ID which we present
the first IP address in each subnet
block
then we have broadcast ID which
indicates the last IP address of the sub
Network block
moving on we have first host ID which is
the immediate first IP address after the
network ID
then we have last host ID as the name
suggests it defines the IP address
before the broadcast ID
continuing we have next network ID
this defines a network ID of the next
subnet block
then we have the total number of IP
addresses
in the sub Network block and lastly we
have subnet mask or cider which
represents the network ID and the host
ID part in an IP address
to better understand all the attributes
of the subnetting
let's take a look at an example
in this example we are assuming an IP
address 192
0.168.0 point x with a subnet mask of
24.
for this IP address we have divided it
into four parts that represent slash 25
27 27 and last part AS Slash 26.
now let's find out the details that
means the attributes for the sub Network
slash 25.
the first attribute is the number of IP
addresses
going by the table we have 0 to 256
addresses in a single block
but in this slash 25 represent only 0 to
128 that means the total number of
addresses in slash 25 subnet block is
128.
moving on we'll find out subnet mask or
cider
that is the default subnet mask of Class
C which I have taken reference from the
subnet table which was explained in the
earlier slide
purchase 255.255.255.128
then we have the network ID
which represents the top most Network
address in the sub Network Block in our
case it is 192.168.0.0
then we have broadcast ID which is the
last IP address in any sub Network Block
in our case it has 192.168.0.127
moving on the network ID and the
broadcast ID addresses cannot be
assigned to any network device in the
network
because the network ID is used to
identify the sub Network Block in a
network
along with the broadcast ID which is
used to communicate with any of the
hosts that is connected to the sub
Network block
that also means that the total number of
usable network ID addresses in a network
block is total number of IP addresses
minus 2 that represents network ID and
broadcast ID
that would be 128 minus 2
and we get the value of 126. which
represents the total number of IP
addresses that are usable
moving on the next attribute is first
host ID
that means the first ID after the
network ID which is 192.168.0.1
then we have the last host ID
which is
192.168.0.126 which is just before the
broadcast ID
and lastly the next network ID
which is 192.168.0.128
now that we are clear about all the
characteristics of our sub Network how
about our practice round for everyone to
find all the characteristics for the sub
Network block slash 27 subnet mask
you can give your answers in the comment
section
let's move on to the benefits of using
subnetting
where the first benefit is enhanced
Network efficiency
through the use of applications of
subnetting we can share data through not
only a specific portion of the network
model rather than broadcasting to the
whole network causing unnecessary
traffic in the channel as shown in the
example
over here we see four different hosts
and if we want to share a specific data
put only two of the host we can subnet
them into specific parts
through this the router will only send
data to the specific portion of a sub
Network rather than broadcasting to the
whole network channel this will prevent
Network traffic
moving on the other benefit of using
subnetting process is
network security
subtracting also provides protection to
an extent against any hacking attempts
made on the network model due to the
complexity of the sub networks as
presented in the example
during the hacking attempt if we can
identify how the virus attacks the
network model we can prevent it from
attacking all the sub networks by
compromising a single or two of them and
preventing the remaining subnetworks
let's move on to the drawbacks of using
subnetting process
the very first drawback of using the
subnetting process is it makes the
network model much more complex which in
turns affects the maintenance and
efficiency
then we have the unused IP addresses
which are left over from applying the
network model in a sub Network process
and lastly we have the low efficiency
use of Hardware devices if the hardware
devices such as router or switches used
are of low efficiency
the performance of the sub Network water
switching techniques
switching techniques are network
techniques responsible for overseeing
the transmission of data over different
communication channels they are also
responsible for choosing the best route
for data transfer
next we will look into why to apply
these switching techniques
using the switching techniques we can
choose the best and the most efficient
route for data transfer in the network
for example
if we want to send some data from node a
to node B we can do so by
moving from node a to a switch then node
D then to node B but doesn't this seems
like too long this is where the
switching techniques plays its role
using the switching Technique we can
choose the smallest and the most
efficient way that is no day switch then
to the node B
next we will look into different types
of switching techniques
switching techniques can be divided into
three primary types the first is
circuit switching
that requires a predestined path for
data transmission
then we have message switching which
integrates the destination address with
the data for transmission
and in the end we have packet switching
that divides its message into smaller
units known as packets
packet switching can further be divided
into two different types that are
virtual switching and datagram switching
now let's look into some details
regarding each of the types
on the first node we have circuit
switching in circuit switching for data
transmission to occur a pre-established
path is required between the sender and
the receiver node
for example
assume that we call someone then this
request is sent over to the network
searches
and a root is to be established for the
signal to pass through
after that system assigns a route for
the signal to pass through then
the receiver receives the call from the
caller side
this is how it works
now let's look into some points to
remember about socket switching
for socket switching we require a
dedicated Channel established between
the source and the destination node for
the network to pass through
the data transmission can take place
only after the path established
and the last point to remember is
other than the sender and the
destination node no node can interfere
with the transmission of data to the
established route
let's look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying circuit
switching in a network
for first one we have advantages
data transmission in circuit switching
is sure to be established due to the
predestined path
circuit switching is preferred for long
and continuous transmission of data due
to the pre-established path route
then let's look into some disadvantages
the time required to establish the
connection is quite long due to the time
required to establish a path
also due to the continuous transmission
of data in circuit switching more
bandwidth is required for maintaining
the connection
let's move on with message switching
in message switching no predestined path
is established between the sender and
the destination node in the message
this technique integrates the
destination address into the data
transmitted and shared over the network
let's look into the setup to better
understand the working of message
switching
for First Step the sender node
integrates the destination address into
the message
then the whole message is transmitted to
the switching node in the network where
it gets stored for the next transmission
and similarly like the Second Step this
transmission of data is done over the
whole network
and finally
through the destination address in the
data it reaches the receiver's node
this is how the message switching works
let's take a look at some points to
remember about message switching
in message switching no predestined path
is established
it uses Dynamic routing as the message
is transmitted through the communication
channel in real time
the each node in network switching
stores the data unless it is transferred
over to the next switch load
let's take a look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying method
switching
to begin with let's take a look at the
advantages
the size of the data that can be
transmitted over message switching is
variable
in message switching the use of
bandwidth is done in an efficient manner
now let's look into some disadvantages
for message switching the nodes that are
known as the switch node is to be
provided with sufficient storage memory
there is a delay in reaching a
destination due to the message technique
that is the message has to stop at each
of the switch node before it is
transferred over to the destination node
now let's look into the last switching
technique that is packet switching
in packet switching the message is
broken into smaller data units known as
packets
these packets are appended with relevant
Network details for the transmission
over the network
let's look into the working of packet
switching
we know that in packet switching the
data is broken into smaller units
packets
which each packet is given a sequence
number for identification
these packets are integrated with
required sender and receiver address and
switching method to choose the smallest
route to reach the destination node
these packets are then recombined at the
destination node in the correct sequence
order
now let's look into some points to
remember for packet switching
for pocket switching all the data
packets that are provided with unique
number for identification at the
receiver end that is
1 2 3 and 4 in the previous example we
just used
packet switching chooses the most
shortest part possible for the data to
reach the destination
in case we have unreached packet or some
unattained packet the whole message from
the sender site is sent again
to the receiver end
now let's look into some details
regarding advantages and disadvantages
of applying packet switching
advantages of using packet switching is
it provides rerouting in case the
network node is busy
it also allows multiple users to access
the same network and no predestined path
is needed
the disadvantage of applying packet
switching is the protocols that are
needed for the working of packet
switching is very complex
there are often cases of loss of data
packets during the transmission in case
of overloading or Corruption of data
now let's look into some information
about the go back and arq protocol
this protocol applies the sliding window
method for transmission of data in the
network channel
where n in the protocol refers to the
window size assigned in the network
model
as for the term erq in the protocol
refers to the automatic repeat request
which means the sender side will send
multiple data frames to the receiver
side according to the assigned window
size
and only after it receives an
acknowledgment from the receiver site
will it continue to send the frames from
the sender side
moving on let's look into some important
points regarding the protocol
as to begin with the method applied to
share multiple frames from the sender
site to the receiver side is known as
the protocol pipelining
where each frame is assigned a sequence
number for proper transmission of data
in the network channel
now let's move on to some other
important points
as we already know
the n in the protocol refers to the
window size that is the maximum limit of
frames that can be transmitted from the
sender to the receiver side before
reaching the acknowledgment for the
previous frame
and in case if the transmission of the
acknowledgment of a frame is not
received within a certain time period
then all the frames from that sequence
number are to be retransmitted in the
channel
this point is to be remembered properly
because this will be the key point in
solving a question related to go back in
arq protocol
now let's move on to the working of the
protocol
to begin with we have a sender site and
a receiver side
along with the sequence number
the window size for the network channel
and the number of frames will already be
assigned in the network
Now by applying the sliding window
protocol we will send the first three
frames from the sequence continuously
which will be frame number zero
frame number one and two
this is assigned according to the window
size
after sending the frames we will have a
sliding window over the sequence number
that are 0 1 and 2.
after the frames are sent to the
receiver site it will use the frames and
send an acknowledgment signal to the
sender side
that would be 0 for the first time
after which we can share the next frame
that will be frame number three from the
sender side to the receiver side
after sending frame 3 the sliding window
from sequence number 0 1 to 2 to shift
over to 1 2 and 3.
and similarly
for frame number one we will receive the
acknowledgment signal from the receiver
side to the sender side
and then we can share the next frame
that is frame number 4 from the sender
side to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift over
from sequence number 1 2 and 3 to over 2
3 and 4.
foreign as for the next frame that is
frame number two when we receive the
acknowledgment from the receiver side
there is a catch
for any network issues the
acknowledgment is not received by the
sender site
so in this case as discussed earlier in
one of the important points the sender
side will not transmit frame number
five
instead it will re-transmit frame number
2 3 and 4.
where the second frame is the one which
did not receive the acknowledgment and
all the frames sent after second frame
is to be retransmitted along with it
that is 3 and 4.
what is peritable check
the parity bit is a data check bit added
to the original data for detecting
errors at the receiver Side by checking
the Integrity of the received data
the parity bit adds 1 or 0 to the
original data that is to be transmitted
to the receiver side
and if in case there's an error in the
received data the center side will do
the penalty check and give the request
for retransmission of the data
now let's move on to the key points
regarding pair debit check
to properly understand the working of
parity bit check
we need to understand some key points
where the first one is redundant bits
where the extra binary width that are
added explicitly to the original data to
prevent the damage to the transmitted
data or to detect the damage to the
transmitted data
they are also used to recover the
original data in case of a damage at the
receiver end
the number of redundant bits added
depends upon the type of check method
used
regarding which in this example there
are four data bits used whereas three
redundant bits
it can also be two redundant bits
or one redundant bit in case of parity
check method only one redundant bit is
added to the original data
now let's move on to the next key point
that is
parity bits
the parity weight check method is a
method to add binary bits to secure the
original data
that is done by counting the total
number of ones in the original data
which is either even or odd number
the parity bit check method is used to
detect error in the original data at the
receiver side and also in some cases it
is used to correct the change
there are two types of parity bits
available to choose from the first one
is odd predictable in this parity bit
check the number of ones in the original
data including the parity bit should be
odd number for example
in the given example the number of green
tiles has four ones that is even so the
parity bit should be one in this case to
make the total number of ones in the
data 5 that is odd
similarly the other parity bit is known
as even parity bit in this case of
parity type the total number of ones
counted is to be even including the
parity bit for example
the number of ones in green tiles is
four that is even so the value of parity
bit should be 0 in this case
the point to be noted is the parity bit
value should always be correct because
it acts as the error detection method at
the receiver side
now let's move on to the explained
example to consolidate all the things we
have learned so far
the question is for the given data bit
that is one one zero one one apply the
even parity bit check for data
transmission
now let's begin
for the first step let's take the
original data
that is one one zero one one one
and the parity bit value is to be given
as p
now according to the next step we have
to count the number of ones in the
original data
which will come out to be
5 bits that means there are five ones in
the original data which represents an
odd number
to balance this according to even parity
bit now we have to add 1 in place of P
so the new data to be transmitted will
become 1 1 0
1 1 1 and 1. which will be transmitted
to the receiver site
by the sender site
after the data has reached the receiver
side there are a few cases that may
arise in the data where each one is the
data bit received to transmission has no
errors that is the data received is
correct after applying the parity bit
check
which in this case is even
so the transmitted data is this
and the received data is this that means
both the transmitted data and received
data are same that means the received
data is correct then the second case
arises is the data bit received two
transmission has errors that is the data
received is damaged after applying the
even parity check
which in this case the transmitted data
is
and the received data has an 0 instead
of 1.
which means the number of ones in this
case becomes 5. which does not match
with the even parity check so it has an
error
and the last Case Case three in this the
data bit received through transmission
has errors that is the data received is
correct according to the even parity bit
because the transmitted data has six
ones whereas the received data has four
ones but according to even parity check
only the number of ones should be even
that means the number of ones received
by the receiver site is four so
according to parity bed check it is
valid but
according to the original data the
received data is wrong
these are the three main cases that may
arise during the transmission of data
through parity check method
in this interactive demo session on the
top networking commands we will look
into some of the most popular commands
applied by users to handle network
issues and save precious time so stay
tuned
but before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from us
to begin practicing the commands we need
to access the command prompt application
using the CMD command in the start menu
now let's begin with the list of
commands the first command is ipconfig
this command displays the system's basic
IP address configuration data which
includes Network information about IP
addresses subnet masks and default
gateway
similarly we also have ipconfig slash
all command which displays all the
details regarding our device like Lan
settings physical address of the system
IP addresses subnet masks and DHCP
information
let's use the CLS command to clear the
application window for the next one the
next command is hostname which is used
to access the system's hostname
to verify this let's use the ipconfig
slash all command to check the hostname
in the information and for sure we have
the same hostname
let's perform the CLS command again and
perform the next command
the Ping command is used to check the
communication availability of the
destination host and the user system
for example use a ping command with
google.com to check the server
availability which gives us the
following result
also using the results IP address and
then the pin command we can get the same
result in case we just don't have the
domain name
we perform the CLS command again and
move on to the next one the nslookup
command is used to troubleshoot network
connectivity and find the IP address of
a domain like Google and Amazon as
applied just now to receive the name and
address of the domain
also using the nslookup command and then
applying the server command with an IP
address we can get the domain name
belonging to the IP address
and similarly to check the number of
servers with the same domain name we can
do this and we have four name servers
for Google
we perform the CLS command again and
move on to the next one
the tracered command is used to
troubleshoot the routing issues of the
network by displaying the routing table
through which the data is transmitted to
a maximum of 30 hops in the network as
you can see
similarly you can also try amazon.com
and share your views in the comment
section below now let's clear the
application window and perform the next
command which is the ARP command this
command is applied to display the
communication exchange between the IP
address and the systems Mac or physical
address
let's move on to the next command which
is the path ping command
this combines the preset and ping
commands and displays detailed
information as an output for a maximum
of 30 hops in the network
this command takes some time to compile
the full hop details so that you can
share findings in the comment section
next we have the netstat command it's
used to display the network connection
summary of the system as shown in the
demo
similarly if we use the netstat hyphen n
command it will give us much more
details about the connection and UDP
details
next we have the net share command which
displays the details of where the data
resources for our system are shared and
we can check them under the share name
resources and remark column
then we have the route command that
allows us to access the routing tables
and also allows us to make changes to
them
let's try the route print command and we
have the interface list ipv4 routing
table details with all the active routes
and the IPv6 routing table moving on
let's clear the window and look at the
net sh command the netsh is a popular
command which allows us to view and
configure the network adapters in the
system
under the net sh command we have
multiple functions for configuring
settings let's try the show command and
we have the following result
moving on we have the task list command
that lists all the currently working
applications on the system with task or
program ID and the memory it uses let's
perform an example
access Google Chrome and then perform
the task list command and as expected we
have the Chrome details in the list
and if we close the Chrome window and
again use the task list command we don't
have the application active
similarly we also have the task skill
command which will terminate the task
corresponding to the given program ID in
the command window
for example let's access Chrome and
perform the task list command to check
the program ID
and then we'll use it with the task kill
command and we can see that the
application is terminated
to check our result we can access the
task list command again next on the list
we have the system info command
it's used to view all the information
about the system from the windows
version to the BIOS and booting
configuration
you can access all these details using
the system info command and the last
Network command for this section is the
wmic command
for getting detailed information on the
ports and functions of the system like
CPU details and then similarly we can
check the bio settings if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security or a networking
professional by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with
networking by learning from the experts
then try giving a show to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of Engineering the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
introduction to the algorithm
foreign
was invented by edscar w dextra
this algorithm were designed to find the
shortest path
between the nodes of a communication
Channel
the distance algorithm is also used to
form a shortest part table for the given
graph
and it works on the principle of greedy
algorithm
now let's move on to some key points
regarding the algorithm
the first key point to be noted to solve
a dextra's algorithm is the algorithm is
closely linked to position of the nodes
in a graph
the next point is the attribute value
between the nodes of a channel
is used to deduce the shortest path
as for the last point we have the
initial value of all the nodes from the
current node is assumed to be infinite
to much practically understand the
functioning of the dextra's algorithm
let's take a look at the principle for
the same
the principle of the algorithm works as
if the distance of U that represents the
current node plus the length that is the
attribute value between node U that is a
current node and node V that is the
target node is less than the attribute
value to distance of the target node
and also the distance of the target node
is equal to the distance of current node
plus the length between Target node and
the current node
where distance U represents the source
node or the current node
and distance V represents the target
node or the destination node
to much better understand let's apply
this
for the given question let's find the
shortest path
in this given example we have three
different nodes node a b and c
using the previously discussed algorithm
principle we will deduce the shortest
path
for Note 8 to the other nodes in the
graph that is the shortest path from
node a to node B and the shortest part
from node a to node C
for this let's take the node B first
according to the solution it should be
for node B on applying the algorithm
along with the values we have if 0 that
is the position of a is 0 plus the
target node attribute value that is 10.
is less than equal to infinite that is
initially as mentioned infinite value is
to be assumed
and this statement stands true so the
distance between node a to node B
becomes 10.
for the third step we will look into
distance between node a to node C that
would be 0 plus 40. that is the direct
connection between node a to node C
according to the example Which is less
than infinity again true so the distance
between note a to node C is 40.
Moving on but we have to find the
shortest path
so for this fourth step comes into
picture
that is for node C from node B on
applying the algorithm we have
10 that is the initial value of node B
and plus 15 that is the attribute value
between B and node C
which is 25 and is less than infinity
so the shortest path between node a to
node C becomes 25 instead of 40 which
was given through step 3.
using the same scenario and same steps
we will solve a much difficult question
and understand how the algorithm is used
then without further Ado let's move on
to the solved example using the text
trans algorithm
according to the given question
we have to use the distrust algorithm
for the given graph and find the
shortest path from node a to node C
the point to be noted is we need to find
distance that is shortest between node a
to node C only
now let's take a look at the graph
and this is the given graph
with node a at the current node
and node C is to be the targeted node
but before we begin with the solution
for the given graph let's take a look at
some of the important points to remember
the first point the distance of node a
from all the other nodes is infinite in
the starting step as discussed earlier
in the example graph
the next point is the node with the
shortest value will become the next
current node
then we have
this graph is done to maintain a proper
shortest path value table which will be
very helpful during the solution of the
graph
now let's move on to the solution
to begin with we will make
shortest path table value
that is given through this
with three columns on it node column
value column and previous node
now let's start with the actual solution
to begin with the first step is to Mark
the current node that is node a
then the nodes that are directly
connected to the current node that is
node B and node d
Now using the value distance that is 3
for node a to node B and 8 for node a to
node D we will update our table
where the point will be noted is that we
have updated the previous node as a for
both the nodes V and D
moving on now let's choose the next
current node that is
node B
for the next case because the shortest
path in the given table is 3 which is
less than 8.
now
the directly connected nodes to node br
node D and no d
similar to the case we did earlier we
will Mark the shortest distance from
node B to node D and Nod let's reduce
the distance
the distance between node B to node D is
3 plus 5 that is equal to 8.
and then we have
distance from node we to node D that is
3 plus 6.
so the value is 9.
now we will update our
shortest path table and the new table
comes up to be
from node d
to node B we have 8 and node B to node e
we have 9 with the previous node as B
moving on let's decide the next current
node that is
D because the shortest distance is 8 in
comparison to 9 for node e
so the new current node is node D and
the directly connected nodes to node D
is node e and node f
the point to be noted is the current
node is chosen only from the unvisited
nodes
now for this we have
distance between node D to node e is 8
that is the previous value we did used
plus 3 that is the distance between node
D to node d and the total value comes up
to be 11.
then we have to node F from node T that
is 8 plus 2 that is the distance between
node D and node f
so the value becomes 10.
on updating the shortest path graph
table we have
the new distances that is node F has 10
value with the previous node as D and
there is no change with the node d
because in comparison to 8 11 is much
bigger
moving on let's choose the next current
node that is
node e because in comparison the value
10 from node F 9 is smaller
now the node e is a current node and the
directly connected nodes are node F and
node C
now let's find the value between node C
and node e
that will be 9 plus 9 that is the
distance between node e and node C so
the value totals come up to be 18.
and for node F and node e we have 9 plus
1 that is the distance between node e
and node F that comes up to be 10.
now let's compare with the graph table
where node f is originally at Value 10
and again the value is 10 so there's no
change and see we have infinite and the
value 18 is much smaller so the new
graph would be something like this
with node c as 18 value and previous
node as e
now let's decide the next current node
that is
node F because the distance value is
lowest in the given graph that is 10 and
for node C is 18.
and the directly connected node is node
C
then the distance comes up to be 10 plus
3 that is 13.
using this 13th value we can decide the
current value of C is 18 and the new
value is 13. in comparison 13 is
obviously less so the new graphs comes
out to be
for node C value 13 and the previous
node becomes f
with the completion of all the nodes in
the given graph we can deduce the
shortest path from node a to node C that
comes up to be
from node a to node D node D to node F
and node F to node C and the total value
comes up to be 13.
with this we have covered all the parts
regarding the functioning and the
working steps involved in the dikshas
algorithm
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section
introduction to distance Vector routing
distance Vector routing refers to the
distance or the vector that is between
the neighboring nodes
in a network channel
and the routing part refers to the
established route through which data
packets are transmitted in the network
channel
the other aspect of this routing
protocol in a network channel is to
determine the shortest path for a data
packet in the network to reach its
destination
next we will look into some key points
regarding the routing protocol
for routing protocol three primary key
points are to be remembered
first one being
each router in this protocol is designed
to share the vector data of each node
throughout the network
this step is done to maintain proper
circulation of data in the network
channel
the next key point is the routing
pattern in the network protocol
that is the data shared by the routers
is transmitted only to those nodes that
are directly linked to a particular
router
the last key point is that the routing
protocol is designed in a manner that it
shares the updated Vector data
periodically at the network channel
now let's move on to the next heading
that is the algorithm used in the
protocol
the algorithm used in this protocol is
termed as Bellman fold algorithm
this algorithm defines the shortest path
that the data packet can take to reach
its destination node from my initial
node
where
P of X Y refers to the least distance
from a node X to node y
moving on we have C of X comma V where X
is caused from each of its neighboring V
node is taken into consideration
then we have D of v y
this is a distance of each neighbor from
its initial node
and lastly
minor fee this is an abbreviation used
to determine the most shortest Vector
after the solution is obtained using the
algorithm
in the next heading that is Network
example we will understand all the
points used in the algorithm
now let's design a network model with
five different nodes
that are a b c and d
with each node connected to each other
using different network channel
the numerical values in the network
channel refers to the vector count that
is the distance from node a to node b or
to some other node in the network
channel
in a network model each node share its
Vector data with its neighboring node at
a regular interval as there are various
updates in the network model
this data is shared in a form of routing
table where three different columns are
used
first being destination column second
Vector column that is the distance node
and lastly the Hop
let's take a look at the neighboring
nodes for this model
for node a we have b and e as it is
directly interlinked to the node a
for node B we have node a and node C
for node C we have B and D
for D we have c and e and lastly for E
we have node a and node d
these nodes represents only the
neighboring nodes
now let's solve an actual example on
routing protocol to clear all our doubts
and understand the key points
the example we'll be taking to solve is
this network model
the initial step to start solving the
network model using the distance Vector
routing protocol is to make routing
table for each of the nodes
let's make the routing table for node a
this is the routing table for no day
where we have destination as a
that means destination is a from node a
that means the distance Vector should be
zero
then we have destination as B
let's take a look in this given example
there is no given connection between A
and B that means
this distance Vector would be Infinity
then we have destination as C
similarly as node B there is no direct
connection between a and node C that
means this is also Infinity
and same is the case with node d
and in the end we have
node e that is the only directly linked
node
to node a that means the distance given
is 5 so the network Vector is 5.
let's make an another routing table for
node e
this is the routing table for nodi
let's take a look
in this routing table the first is
destination to node a
according to the network model given
distance is 5 so the vector value is 5
with the Hop to a
then we have
destination as node B according to the
model the distance Vector should be 4.
then we have destination as node C as
given there is no direct connection
between node e and node C that
determines the value would be Infinity
then we have node d
which represents
direct connection with node e and the
value is 7.
and lastly
e destination from initial Point e would
be zero vector
now let's make another routing tables
similarly for node C
Now using the same steps you can make
the routing table for the remaining
nodes that is node B and node d
now let's move on to the next step in
solving the routing issue
this step is known as updates
in this step we use the vector column
from each of the node to update the
vector column or the routing table for a
particular node
in this part we'll use
node is Vector column to update the
routing table for node a
and the steps are using the algorithm
that is the Bellman fold algorithm we
used earlier
as we already know moving from a to
destination node a is always zero so we
won't be doing this step let's move on
to the next one that is moving from node
a to node B
that would be
would be a comma e as we are using
Vector column of node e
plus and the distance used to reach E
from B
a comma e represents 5.
and E to B represents 4 according to the
network model so the value is 9.
similarly let's solve for a to c
to a to c we have a comma e plus
destination required to move from E to C
according to the network model we have
node a is only directly linked with node
e so the value would be 5 but there is
no connection between node e and node C
so the value would be Infinity
moving on we have
a to d
in this case we have a comma e the value
would be 5 plus e to D that is a direct
connection and the value would be 7 so
the total distance is 12.
and the last one is a to e for this we
have a comma e that is directly the
neighboring node the value would be 5.
so the new routing table for node a is
0 9 Infinity 12 and 5.
similarly let's take another node for
this
for the next node we will take note C
and we will update the routing table of
node C using its neighboring nodes that
are
node B and node D according to the
network model
now how to do this step
firstly it's C to destination a
in case of node B we have
C to a that would be C comma B that is a
direct connection plus distance required
from B to a
according to the network model we have C
comma b as 6 plus b to a does not have
any connection that is infinity so the
value would be null
then we have node D in this case we have
C comma D that is a direct connection 3
plus d to a that is again Infinity
as it is not linked directly to node a
moving on we have destination as B
for node B we have direct connection so
C comma B value is 6. whereas for node D
we have
C comma D that is distance 3 plus d to B
that is infinity as it is not directly
linked with the node B
so again the value is null
then we have
destination as C so connection between C
to C is 0.
moving on we have destination at node d
that would be C to d as C to D
as there is no direct connection between
node B and node D so the value is
infinity
whereas for C to D is a direct
connection for node D so the value would
be 3.
now for the pass node that is node e
in case of node B we have C comma B plus
b to e where the value for C to B node
is 6 and B2 is 4 so the sum is 10.
and now in case of node D we have
3 plus 7 that would be distance from C
to D and then D to e and the value would
be again 10 so we can use any of the
side to reach the destination node e
by completing all the steps we have the
new table for node C
similarly we can find the routing table
for all the nodes present
now to look into some key points we
learned
for the initial step use only the node
distance of immediate Neighbors
nodes without distance that is directly
linked to each other is always infinity
for the update step use the vector table
of the only neighboring node we have for
the initial node
and lastly to continue the update step
roughly n minus 1 iterations are used
where the value of n is equal to the
number of nodes
for example the model we took has five
nodes that means we have to do a loop of
four iterations what is hdlc
let's take a look
the hdlc stands for high level data link
control refers to the bit oriented
Network protocol design to connect
multiple Network system according to the
communication requirement
the hdlc model applies the arq protocol
for application and establishes a full
duplex Communication channel between the
network devices
moving on we have the different types of
hdlc stations available
hdlc stations can efficiently be
differentiated into three different
types where the first type is primary
station
in this station it handles the
establishing and destabilishing of the
primary data channel to share different
frames in the network channel
known as commands
it also performs the data management for
the network
moving on we have the secondary station
this station work under the command of
the primary station and the frames
issued by the stations are known as
responses
as for the last station we have combined
station as the name suggests this type
of station is available for both
commands and response value
next we will look into hdlc transfer
models
the hdlc protocol supports two types of
transfer models which are applied
according to the need of Communication
channel where the first type is known as
normal response model or in short nrm
this transfer model combines the primary
station and the secondary station in a
point to point or multi-point
configuration
to exchange commands from primary
station and responses from the secondary
station
and response to the multi connection
moving on we have the second type of
transfer model which is asynchronous
balance model
in this transfer model the combined
stations are installed in a
point-to-point configuration for
exchange of command or responses from
either of the node
moving on let's take a look at the hdlc
frame model and types
the data unit for sharing information in
the hdlc protocol is known as frames
the hdlc frame consists of multiple
frame fields which may varying according
to the frame type
in general the hdlc frame consists of
five different frame Fields where the
first field is flag field
in hdlc each frame starts and with the
flag field in the configuration and is
defined by an 8-bit octet sequence which
is 0 1 1 1 1 1 0 in the flag feed
moving on we have the address field it
encapsulates the receiver's address in
the field for example if the frame is
sent from the primary station it
contains the secondary station's address
and vice versa
next we have the control field this
field contains the flow and error
control information in byte format
next we have payload or the information
field it carries the actual information
from the upper layer of the OSI model
and the last field is known as FCS field
this field stands for frame sequence
check and acts as an error detection
field in the hdlc protocol which
includes a 6-bit CRC check
given is a frame format for an hdlc
protocol
with flag in the both ending and the
starting point followed by address field
control field information field and FCS
field
now let's take up a quiz
to understand all the things we have
learned so far
the question is
the hdlc protocol functions under which
network layer in the USM model
and the options are
application layer data link layer
physical layer and the network layer
you can give your answers in the comment
section
now let's move on to different types of
frame models available in hdlc
the free models in hdlc can be
classified of following three types
depending upon the control field value
of the frame
where the first frame is known as iframe
the iframe stands for information frame
and is applied to encapsulate the user
information from the upper layer in the
model
and then transmit it to the network
channel
note the first bit of the control field
in this Frame is always zero which also
acts as an identification point for
iframe
moving on we have the S frame the S
frame stands for supervisory frame and
is used for error and data flow control
and does not contain any information
regarding the information field in the
format
not for the S frame s the first two bits
of the control field is 1 and 0. which
acts as an identification point for S
frame
as for the last type of frame model we
have U frame the u-frame stands for
unnumbered frame used for system
management and exchanging information
between connected network devices
with this we have covered all the
relevant information regarding the hdlc
protocol
the 6m is one of the most applied error
detection method in the network channel
and is a bit based format detection
method
the checksum uses checksum generator on
the sender side to form the checksum
method and the checksum checker on the
receiver side to check whether this an
error in the data or not
let's continue with the next setting
that is why to apply checksum method
using the checksum method at the center
side the checksum value is added to the
original data to being transferred as an
error detection method whereas at the
receiver side it decodes the incoming
data from the sender side according to
the checksum method
to detect any changes in the given data
now let's move on to the working steps
involved in the checksum method
there are various steps involved in the
checksum method let's take a look at the
first step that is the first step begins
at the sender side where we divide the
original data into K parts of n Bits
continuing with adding all the cave
blocks we have obtained
then the addition result is complemented
using one's complement
the data now obtained is known as the
checksum value
next let's look at the step two
data transmission after we have received
the checksum value from the checksum
method we will add it to the front of
the original data and transfer it to the
network channel to the receiver side
now step 3 step 3 begins at the receiver
site that is
it will divide that is the receiver side
will divide the obtained original data
plus each XM value into clay box
and then add all the K blocks using
addition
after that we will complement the
obtained data
if the complement of 1 comes out to be
0.
that is no errors are received in the
data and the receiver will accept the
data whereas for case 2 if the result is
not 0 the received data is damaged
so the receiver will discard this data
and request for retransmission of data
from the sender side
now after understanding all the points
regarding working of the checksum method
let's take a look at a solved example to
better understand all the points
the question is for the given data
perform the checksum method
this is how we divided all the four
parts
each of these represents a key block
that is four blocks and eight bits in
each of the block that is n Bits
now for the first step that is at the
sender side
we will add all the given data
so the value would come out to be one
zero zero zero that would be 1.
0100 would be one
zero zero one one would be one carry 0
so 1 carry plus one means zero plus one
carry again
one carry plus one means zero and one
1 0 1 that is one carry 0 plus 1 plus 0
means one so one carry is over order
this side
1 plus 0 is 1 1 plus 1 is 1 carry zero
zero plus zero zero zero plus zero is
zero and zero and we have one carry over
here
so the obtained data would be 1 0 with
extra bit as this
now to resolve this issue we will now
add the extra carry to the obtained data
from the addition part that would be
1 0 1 0 0 1 0 0.
now
add the sender side you will do one's
complement for the obtained addition
value that would come out to be one one
zero one one zero one zero that is the
checksum value
now this value addition to the original
data will be shared to the receiver side
where at the receiver side we will again
perform the addition method
and the value comes out to be
this along with two digits of extra bit
that is the carry again similarly we
will add this carry to the addition
value and get the new data that is all
ones now again going by the steps we
have to perform one's complement for
this value obtained that comes out to be
all zeros that means the checksum value
is 0 at the receiver side which
indicates that there are no errors in
the received data by the receiver side
with this we have completed all the
points regarding working of the checksum
method now to better understand all the
steps let's take up a quiz
that is for the given data find the
checksum value
where the given options can be one of
them you can give your answers in the
comment section what is peritable check
the parity bit is a data check bit added
to the original data for detecting
errors at the receiver Side by checking
the Integrity of the received data
the parity bit adds 1 or 0 to the
original data that is to be transmitted
to the receiver side
and if in case there is an error in the
received data the sender side will do
the penalty check and give the request
for retransmission of the data
now let's move on to the key points
regarding pair debit check
to properly understand the working of
parity bit check we need to understand
some key points where the first one is
redundant bits
where the extra binary width that are
added explicitly to the original data to
prevent the damage to the transmitted
data or to detect the damage to the
transmitted data
they are also used to recover the
original data in case of a damage at the
receiver end
the number of redundant bits added
depends upon the type of check method
used
regarding which in this example there
are four data bits used whereas three
redundant bits
it can also be two redundant widths or
one redundant bit
in case of parity check method only one
redundant bit is added to the original
data
now let's move on to the next key point
that is
parity bits
the parity with check method is a method
to add binary depicts to secure the
original data
that is done by counting the total
number of ones in the original data
which is either even or odd number
the parity bit check method is used to
detect error in the original data at the
receiver site and also in some cases it
is used to correct the change
there are two types of priority bits
available to choose from the first one
is odd palette in this parity bit check
the number of ones in the original data
including the parity bit should be order
number for example
in the given example the number of green
tiles has four ones that is event so the
parity bit should be one in this case to
make the total number of ones in the
data 5 that is odd
similarly the other parity bit is known
as even parity bit in this case of
parity type the total number of ones
counted is to be even including the
parity bit for example
the number of ones in green tiles is
four that is even so the value of parity
bit should be 0 in this case
the point to be noted is the parity bit
value should always be correct because
it acts as the error detection method at
the receiver site
now let's move on to the explained
example to consolidate all the things we
have learned so far
the question is for the given data bit
that is one one zero one one apply the
even parity bit check for data
transmission
now let's begin
for the first step let's take the
original data that is one one zero one
one
and the parity bit value is to be given
as p
now according to the next step we have
to count the number of ones in the
original data
which will come out to be
5 bits that means there are five ones in
the original data which represents an
odd number
to balance this according to even parity
bit now we have to add 1 in place of P
so the new data to be transmitted will
become one one zero one one one and one
which will be transmitted to the
receiver site
by the sender site
after the data has reached the receiver
side there are a few cases that may
arise in the data where case one is the
data we received to transmission has no
errors that is the data received is
correct after applying the parity bit
check which in this case is even
so the transmitted data is this
and the received data is this that means
both the transmitted data and received
data are same that means the received
data is correct then the second case
arises is the data bit received two
transmission has errors that is the data
received is damaged after applying the
even parity check
which in this case the transmitted data
is
and the received data has an 0 instead
of one
which means the number of ones in this
case becomes 5. which doesn't match with
the even parity check so it has an error
and the last Case Case three in this the
data bit received through transmission
has errors that is the data received is
correct according to the even parity bed
because the transmitted data has six
ones whereas the received data has four
ones but according to even parity check
only the number of ones should be even
that means the number of ones received
by the receiver side is 4 so according
to parity bed check it is valid but
according to the original data the
received data is wrong
these are the three main cases that may
arise during the transmission of data
through parity check method the Heming
code method is a network technique that
is designed to detect errors and correct
data bits which are transmitted during
data Exchange
it was first implemented by RW Hamming
hence the name humming code
this network technique is implemented
because during data transmission there
are often cases where data loss or data
damage occurs
to recover or detect the damage in the
original data we use Hamming code
in the next slide we will look into some
terms that are related to the working of
Hamming code
the first one being redundant widths
these are the extra binary bits that are
added explicitly to the original data
bit
to prevent damage to the transmitted
data
and also to recover the original data in
case of a damage at the receiver end
in the next point we will look into some
formula related to redundant bits and
how to add them in the Hamming code
the formula related to redundant bits is
to R more than equal to M plus r Plus 1.
where M refers to the data bits in the
data and R refers to the Redundant bits
let's take an example
in case m is equal to 4 that means the
data bits used are four we need to find
the value of r
using the above formula let's deduce the
value of redundant bits
2R is more than equal to 4 plus r Plus
1.
2 to the power r is more than equal to
R plus 5
so using this let's use r equal to 0 if
we use that we will get a value 1 that
is more than equal to R plus 5 but that
is wrong
then using r equal to 3 that is 8 is
more than equal to
8.
this way we conclude that the Hamming
code would be 7 bit data because the
value of R is 3 and M is 4.
now let's move on to the next
term related to Hamming code
that is parity pills the parity bit is a
method to append binary bits to secure
that the total number of counts of 1 in
the original data is either even number
or an odd number
let's take a look why do we exactly use
parity bills
they are used to detect error in the
original data which occurs during the
transmission of data
through this method
we can detect the error at the receiver
end and also correct it
let's take a look at different types of
parity bits available
first one is even parity bit in this
case of parity type the total number of
ones counted is to be even in the count
in case the count is odd then the value
of parity is 1.
otherwise the value should be zero
similarly the other parity bit is known
as odd parity width
for this parity bit the total number of
ones counted in the original data should
be odd
if that is the case the value of parity
bit should be zero and in case the value
of ones in the original data comes out
to be odd then the parity value would be
1.
now let's move on to the next setting
that is a working example of the Hamming
code
let's take a look
let's begin with the steps to be
followed to solve a Hamming code issue
the first point being the position of
the parity width is determined using 2
to the power n term where n represents
the number series 0 to n
assigning the position for parity bit
using this method would be more clear
giving an example
for the second point we have the
remaining positions represent the data
bit
now let's try using the value of parity
bit for n is equal to 0 that means 2 to
the power 0 is equal to 1. so all the
bits with one in the last position are
used to determine the value
of the parity build
to better understand the assignment
value of parity bit please focus on this
mention table
in this table we can take a look at the
last position that is n is equal to 0.
and see the mentioned number
for P1 we can use a value 1 because n is
equal to 0 and the last position value
is 1.
then is number three because the last
position beta is one
then similarly for number five because n
is equal to 0 and the bit value is 1.
so these three parity value can be used
for and is equal to zero
similarly let's take a look when the N
is equal to 1.
that means 2 to the power 1 is equal to
2. so all the bits with one in the
second position are used to determine
the value of parity bit
now let's take a look at the table to
identify the numbers related to this
parity bit value
the first one being two two to the
presence of one bit in the second
position
then we have P3
presence of one bit in the second
position
similarly the next would be number six
due to the presence of one bit in the
second position
similarly let's take a look at when n is
equal to 2 that means 2 to the power 2
is equal to 4 so all the bits with one
in the third position are used to
determine the value of participate
and this would be 4 5 and 6 number
please read the points very carefully
because next we will solve an example to
better clarify all the concepts
let's move on
the given example is the data bit to be
transmitted is one zero one one
and we have to solve this using the
Hamming code method
so the first step would be applying the
Hamming code method and identify the
given number of data bits that would be
4 according to the question
so the number of parity bit would be 3
where the value would be 1 2 and 4.
according to the power of P expression
that means
we will get something similar to this
this representation is in data bit
format
where the first position is for P1
parity bit
the second for 2 to the power 1 that is
2. P2
and the third one is for 2 to the power
4 that is P4 parity
and let's put the value that is to be
transmitted in the remaining positions
that would be P1 P2 1 p 4 1 0 and 1.
using this bit value we will deduce the
value of P1 P2 and P4 for data
transmission
in this case we are using even parity
for the example
that means the number of ones should be
even
let's take a look
for P1 we have D1 D3 D5 and D7
as mentioned in the earlier slide
so the value would be P1 comma 1
comma 1 and comma 1 according to the
data bits available to us
by the question
that means the value would be 1 because
the number of ones for P1 is odd
so to make it even the value of P1 would
be 1.
similarly for P2 we have D2 D3 D6 and D7
using the same method we will get
P2 1 0 1. so the number of ones for P2
is even so the P2 value would be 0.
next is for P4 the value is D4 D5 D6 and
D7
where P4 has 1 0 and 1 that means the
number of ones is even so again P4 is
equal to 0.
Now using this we get the new bit that
is to be transmitted
that is 1 0 1 0 1 0 1.
after Transmission in case let's say at
position 5 an error occurs
and the value of 1 is converted to 0.
to detect this error at the receiver
side we will use the Hamming code
to begin with we will use the parity
value to cross check the original data
bit that means let's do the parity bit
method for this received data
so for P1 we have D1 D3 D5 and D7
so the number of ones is odd that means
the value of P1 should be 1 to make it
even
then for P2 we have
D2 D3
D6 and D7
so the number of ones is even
that means the P2 value would be 0
now let's move on for P4
that would be 4
D5 D6 and D7 number of ones is one that
means odd so the value of P4 would be 1.
now let's take a look at the results
that we obtained using this method
foremost this shows that the data
transmitted is damaged and we can detect
the error position using this method
that is using the value of parity bits
obtained
where this will lead to 2 to the power
expression that means 2 to the power 0
plus 0 plus 2 to the power 2 that means
5.
that matches with the Assumption we took
now to correct this error we can use
the position that we obtained that is 5.
and replace the zeroth value with one
bit
by doing this we will obtain the
original data
now let's move on to the first heading
that is Introduction to the protocol
the stop in read protocol is a type of
flow control mechanism active in the OSI
model of the data link layer the
transmission of data applies only to the
noiseless channels
where a noiseless channel represents an
ideal Network channel where no frames
are lost duplicated or hacked
moving on we have the Stop and read
protocol is unidirection in transmission
of data that is either sending or
receiving data will only takes place at
an instance
for the third point we have
the Stop and read protocol as the name
suggests is when the sender shares a
data packet to the receiver end
then the sender side has to stop and
wait for the receiver side to send an
acknowledgment before it starts sending
the next data packet
with this point we are now knowledgeable
about the working of the Stop and read
protocol at an elementary level
now let's move on to the next heading
the next setting for the session is
steps involved in the Stop and weight
protocol
the steps for this protocol are divided
into two parts sender and receiver
protocol
let's start with the sender side
the first step is to transmit one data
unit at a time to the receiver End by
the sender side
and the next step is
to transmit the next data until Only
After we receive the acknowledgment from
the receiver end
now let's move on to the receiver side
in receiver side Step 1 is to receive
the data and use the data that is being
sent
then the second step is after the data
has been used by the receiver side it
will send the acknowledgment to the
sender site for further data
transmission
this is how the transmission of data
takes place in the data protocol
now let's move on to the next heading
that is working of stop and weight
protocol
using the previous two headings we can
easily determine the steps involved in
this working
let's take a look
to begin with we have two sides the
sender and the receiver side
the first step is
to send the data from the sender side to
the receiver end
and after the receiver side has used the
data it will send the acknowledgment
signal
meanwhile the sender site has to wait
for the acknowledgment signal
only after it receives the
acknowledgment signal will it send the
next data packet
now that the sender site has sent the
data for the second time the receiver
site will use this data and then only
share the acknowledgment signal
this process of sending data from the
sender side to the receiver side and
receiving acknowledgment from the
receiver side to the sender site
continues for n number of times
according to the given scenario in the
network channel
now let's move on to the next setting
that is also the last setting for this
session that is drawbacks of using stop
and read protocol
the first drawback of using this
protocol is the loss of data
this issue can arise when transmitting
data from the sender site to the
receiver end
it may be due to any issue
due to hacking attempt or network
disruption or any other network related
issue
then
this can also arise when receiving
acknowledgment from the receiver site
now let's move on to the second drawback
the next issue is related to
acknowledgment transmission that is
during the transmission of
acknowledgment signal due to the network
issues
technology signal is disrupted
and the transmission is terminated
this can arise again due to any reasons
that are occurring in the network
channel
now let's move on to the last drawback
for the setting
the last issue occurs due to the delay
in transmission time of the information
time delay drawback can occur on either
side of the transmission that is during
data transmission or the acknowledgment
transmission as we know in the
networking concept protocols refers to
the rules and instructions
that governs the data transmission
between different network models and
devices in a communication Channel
the data transmitted using protocols is
easily handled and is reliable to use as
well as it provides a secure channel for
the data to be transmitted
now let's move on to the different types
of protocols available in a network
channel
the protocols available in a network
channel can be divided into two
different types noiseless channels and
noisy channels
where the noise part refers to any
external interference data error or
duplicate Transmission in the network
channel
furthermore noiseless channels and noisy
channels can be divided into
subdivisions let's take a look at the
noiseless channels first
noiseless channels can be divided into
two types simplest type and stop in
weight type
whereas noisy channels are divided into
three subdivisions
stop and beat arq go back and arq
selective repeat arq
in the noisy Channel go back in arq and
selective repeat arq are the ones that
apply the sliding window protocol for
data transmission over the network
channel
now let's look into some information
regarding sliding window protocol
to begin with the sliding window
protocol is a technique that allows the
share of multiple data frames in a
network channel
where the number of frames shared is
determined by the Windows size assigned
to the network channel
also the frames sent during transmission
are assigned with a sequence number for
efficient print Transmission in the
communication Channel
till this point in the video we have
already learned about the definition of
what is the sliding window protocol
now let's look into the working steps of
the sliding window protocol
to begin with we have a center site and
a receiver site in the network channel
then we require the frames where each
frame is given a sequence number for
this example we are using 0 to 8. which
means a total of 9 frames are available
at the sender side
then using the window size we determine
the number of frames that can be shared
at an instance for example we'll be
using 3 as a window size for this
example
let's start with sending the first frame
that is zero
to the receiver side
after the frame is sent a sliding window
appears on the number of frames
now let's move on to the next
that is frame one
the point to be noted is
before receiving any acknowledgment we
have to send all the frames that are
available according to the window size
that is for this example the window size
is 3 that means we have to send three
frames before we receive any
acknowledgment from the receiver side
let's send the last frame that is frame
2.
now we have to wait for the receiver
site to send the acknowledgment signal
to the sender site before we can send
the next frame now that we have shared
the maximum number of frames the
receiver end will share the
acknowledgment signal for frame 0 with
the sender side after this
acknowledgment is received by the sender
side we can share the next frame in the
list that is frame 3.
after the frame 3 has been sent
see the positioning of the sliding
window
the sliding window not changes from 0 1
2 to 1 to 1 3 frame
this positioning of the sliding window
represents that zeroth frame has already
been acknowledged by the receiver site
whereas the third frame is sent for
acknowledgment from the receiver site by
the sender site
and similarly we have to do the same
pattern for the next two frames that is
frame number one and frame number two
now the sender side will receive the
acknowledgment for frame 1 from the
receiver side
and we can send frame 4 from the sender
side to the receiver side
now see the movement of the sliding
window
the sliding window changes from 1 to 1 3
frame number to two three and four
similarly we can move on to the last
frame
now let's draw some simple conclusion
from all the working steps we have seen
so far
to begin with frame number one and zero
represents the acknowledged frames
whereas the frames within the sliding
window represents
the frames that are waiting
acknowledgment
whereas the remaining frames 5 6 7 and 8
are not yet shared with the receiver
site
now let's move on to the next setting
for the session
difference between stop and weight
protocol and sliding window protocol
the first comparison is on the basis of
working mechanism
where the Stop and beat protocol is
designed to send the data frame at a
single time and wait for the receiver to
send acknowledgment to share the next
frame
as for the sliding window protocol
sender can send multiple frames
simultaneously and then wait for the
corresponding acknowledgment from the
receiver end
let's move on to the next comparison
that is based on the window size
on the basis of window size the Stop and
rate protocol is always fixed at 1.
as for sliding window protocol as we saw
in earlier slides it varies according to
the scenario in the network channel
let's take a look at some other
comparisons too
the next comparison is based on
efficiency and time delay as comparison
on this basis the Stop and read protocol
is efficiently low and suffers from more
time delay
as for sliding window protocol the
efficiency is higher than the Stop and
weight protocol which provides lower
time delay during data transmission
let's move on to the last comparison
sorting and transmission of data
for stop and weight protocol sorting is
not required
and it applies half duplex system for
data transmission
as for sliding window protocol we
require sorting for better efficiency
and is full duplex in nature
with this we have reached the end of the
video now let's look into some
information about the go back and arq
protocol
this protocol applies the sliding window
method for transmission of data in the
network channel
where n in the protocol refers to the
window size assigned in the network
model
as for the term erq in the protocol
refers to the automatic repeat request
which means the sender side will send
multiple data frames to the receiver
side according to the assigned window
size
and only after it receives an
acknowledgment from the receiver site
will it continue to send the frames from
the sender side
moving on let's look into some important
points regarding the protocol
as to begin with the method applied to
share multiple frames from the sender
side to the receiver side is known as
the protocol pipelining
where each frame is assigned a sequence
number for proper transmission of data
in the network channel
now let's move on to some other
important points
as we already know the n in the protocol
refers to the window size that is the
maximum limit of frames that can be
transmitted from the sender to the
receiver side before reaching the
acknowledgment for the previous frame
and in case if the transmission of the
acknowledgment of a frame is not
received within a certain time period
then all the frames from that sequence
number are to be re-transmitted in the
channel
this point is to be remembered properly
because this will be the key point in
solving a question related to go back in
arq protocol
now let's move on to the working of the
protocol
to begin with we have a sender site and
a receiver site along with the sequence
number
the window size for the network channel
and the number of frames will already be
assigned in the network
Now by applying the sliding window
protocol we will send the first three
frames from the sequence continuously
which will be frame number 0
frame number one and two
this is assigned according to the window
size
after sending the frames we will have a
sliding window over the sequence number
that are 0 1 and 2.
after the frames are sent to the
receiver site it will use the frames and
send an acknowledgment signal to the
sender side
that would be 0 for the first time
after which we can share the next frame
that will be frame number three from the
sender side to the receiver side
after sending frame 3 the sliding window
from sequence number 0 1 to 2 will shift
over to 1 2 and 3.
and similarly
for frame number one we will receive the
acknowledgment signal from the receiver
side to the sender side
and then we can share the next frame
that is frame number four from the
sender side to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift over
from sequence number 1 2 and 3 to over 2
3 and 4.
as for the next frame that is frame
number two when we receive the
acknowledgment from the receiver side
there is a catch
for any network issues the
acknowledgment is not received by the
sender site
so in this case as discussed earlier in
one of the important points the sender
side will not transmit frame number
five
instead it will retransmit frame number
2 3 and 4.
where the second frame is the one which
did not receive the acknowledgment and
all the frames sent after second frame
is to be re-transmitted along with it
that is 3 and 4.
to much better understand the solution
for the example we'll be solving later
in the video it is suggested that you
watch the steps involved in the working
of the go back and arq protocol again
now moving forward let's take a look at
some of the advantages and disadvantages
of using the protocol in a network
channel
for advantages we have it increases the
efficiency of transmission of frames
it also allows multiple frames to be
sent at once
and the time delay is low for sharing
the packets
as for disadvantages we have
the tree transmission of frames in case
of an error in the network channel is a
very difficult work
and it also requires the storing of
frames on the receiver side that it
receives from the center side
now that we have learned everything
about the go back and RQ protocol let's
take a look at the much awaited working
example for the same
let's take a look at the problem
statement
in a given Network the number of frames
provided is 10
with the window size assigned as 3 and
for every fourth packet is lost
find the total number of messages or
frames sent from the sender side to the
receiver side
from this question we can get three main
parts that are the number of frames that
are given is 10.
as for the window size is 3 and every
fourth packet is lost
let's take a look at the options
option a27 option B25 option C 22 and
option d29
I'll give you guys a moment to take a
look at the question again
now let's move on to the solution
as usual we have the sender side and a
receiver site
and according to the question we have 10
frames
numbering the frames sequentially we
have frame 1 to frame 10.
and then according to the question we
have window size as three
Now using the sliding window method we
will send the first three frames that is
frame number one two and three from the
sender side to the receiver side that
will be
like this
after sending the frames we'll wait for
the receiver side to send the
acknowledgment
and a sliding window will appear on
frame number one two and three
now the receiver side will send the
acknowledgment for frame 1 to the sender
side
and using this we can send frame number
4 from the sender side to the receiver
side
and the sliding window appear on two
three and four sequence number
and similarly for frame number two we'll
send the acknowledgment from receiver
side to the sender site
and send frame number five from sender
to the receiver side
and the sliding window appears on
sequence number 3 4 and 5.
then again for frame number three we'll
send the acknowledgment from the
receiver side to the sender site
and send frame number six from the
sender to the receiver side
and the sliding window appear on frame
number 4 5 and 6. now let's move on for
the next frame for acknowledgment that
is frame number four
for this Frame according to the given
question every fourth frame is lost
during transmission from the center side
to the receiver side
that means no acknowledgment will be
sent from the receiver side to the
sender site for frame number four in
that regards or any other frame that are
sent after frame number four that is
frame number five and frame number six
similarly frame number five and frame
number six will also get discarded
now let's retransmit according to the go
back in arq protocol
frame number four
frame number five and frame number six
after re-transmission frame number four
will get acknowledged by the receiver
side to the sender site that means we
can send next frame that is frame number
seven from the sequence order
and the sliding window appears on frame
number 5 6 and 7.
similarly let's move on to frame number
five
but before we do that let's count the
position of fifth frame in the
transmission order
one two three four five six seven and
eight
that's correct when we count the
position number for any of the frames
from the beginning we use sequence
not the sequence number given by the
question
that means fifth frame is at the
position number eight from the beginning
that means according to the question it
will get lost during the transmission
from sender to the receiver side
similarly
frame number six and frame number seven
that was sent after fifth frame will
also get discarded
according to the go back in arq protocol
again we will retransmit five six and
seven frame number to receive aside from
the sender site
after re-transmission frame number five
will get acknowledged by the receiver
side and then we can share frame number
eight from the sender to the receiver
side
and the positioning of the sliding
window shift from 567 frame to 6 7 and 8
sequence number
now let's move on to the sixth frame
but according to the positioning order
position of the sixth transmitted frame
is number 12.
that means
it will get lost during transmission
from sender to the receiver side
and similarly frame number seven and
eight will also get discarded by the
receiver side
and again applying go back in our Q
protocol we will retransmit frame number
6 7 and 8.
on re-transmission frame number six will
get acknowledged by the receiver side
and we can share frame number nine from
the sender to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift from
sequence number 678 to 7 8 and 9.
now let's recount the position of the
next frame that is frame number seven
from the beginning
and that would be
16 that means frame number seven will
get lost during transmission from the
sender to the receiver side
and similarly frame number seven eight
and nine is to be retransmitted
according to the go back in arq protocol
now similarly following all the previous
steps we can complete this network model
using go back in our queue protocol but
this is a work you guys have to complete
and find out the total number of packets
that were transmitted from the sender to
the receiver side
and give your answers in the comment
section and the next heading is what is
selective repeat arq protocol
okay
for the first point in selective repeat
IQ protocol we have is
the working principle the working
principle of the asrp protocol is based
on sliding window protocol and it uses a
buffer system for storing either at the
center side or the receiver side during
the data transmission
let's move on to the next point for
Selective repeat arq
the term arq in the protocol defines the
automatic repeat request process that is
designed to perform the task of sending
the next frame for each of the
acknowledged frame
now let's move on to the next heading
next heading is important points about
the protocol
for the first point we have is
the value of n that represents the
window size is same for both sides that
is the value of sender size is equal to
the window size of the receiver side
let's take a look at the next point
in case of selected repeat arq protocol
as the name suggests in case the frame
is not received by the receiver side or
the acknowledges not received by the
sender site as shown in the diagram
in this case the mentioned frame is to
be re-transmitted without affecting any
other frame
let's move on to the next point for this
heading
in case the frames not received by the
receiver side then it will share a
negative acknowledgment signal do the
sender side so that it can re-transmit
the damaged frame
this point forms the basis of the
working process involved in the SRP
protocol so please take a note of this
point
now let's move forward
with the working of the protocol
we'll divide the working process of the
SRP protocol in multiple steps for
better understanding let's move on for
the first step
to begin with we have a sender site and
the receiver side as usual
then we have a sequence of numbers
and our window size
now for the Second Step let's send the
First Data frame that is frame 0.
next is frame one
Frame 2 and frame 3.
these four frames are sent for the
beginning because our window size is 4.
and a sliding window appears from
sequence number zero to sequence number
three
after the receiver side I have received
the center size frames it will
acknowledge the first frame that is
frame 0 and saying the acknowledgment
signal to the sender side
after the sender site receives the first
acknowledgment signal it will again
share the next frame in the sequence
that is
frame number four
and the sliding window will shift from
frame 0 to 3 to 1 to 4.
now similarly let's acknowledge frame
number one from the receiver side to the
sender side
and the center side will share the next
frame in the sequence that is frame
number five to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift from
frame 1 to 4 to sequence number two to
five
now
let's acknowledge frame number two
okay now let's assume that frame number
two is lost or corrupted during the
transmission
in this case if we apply go back in arq
protocol all the frames sent after frame
number two are to be retransmitted that
will be frame number two three four and
five
but
in case of SRP protocol that is
selective repeat argue protocol
only the frame that is lost during
transmission is to be retransmitted
that means
the acknowledgment signal for frame
number three will be sent from the
receiver side to the sender side
and the sender side will then
re-transmit frame number 2 to the
receiver side
this process of re-transmitting only the
loss frame is known as The Selective
repeat arq protocol
and similarly we will acknowledge the
next frame that is frame number four
and send the next frame that will be
frame number six
as you can see
in this process of SRP protocol the
sliding window or the window size
clearly does not play any particular
role
with the completion of this slide we are
done with the whole working steps
involved in the SRP protocol now let's
move on to the next setting in the video
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
the next heading in this session is
difference between selected repeat arq
protocol and go back in RQ protocol
let's take a look
for the first point we have
in go back and IQ protocol it does not
require a large amount of memory
as it does not provide the buffer
feature for the network model
whereas in case of selective repeat arq
protocol it requires a buffer system so
the memory needed is more on both the
sides that is a sender site and the
receiver side
now let's move on to the next point
all the frames after the loss frame in
go back in IQ protocol are to be
re-transmitted as we already discussed
in the earlier slide
whereas in case of selective repeat RQ
protocol only the damaged or the loss
frame is to be re-transmitted
let's take a look at some other points
too
in go back energy protocol too many
re-transmission frames are required so
the efficiency of the overall model is
very low
and in case of SRP protocol the
re-transmission the frames is less
so the efficiency of the overall model
is increased
let's take a look at the last point for
the difference
the bandwidth required for go back and
acute protocol is too high due to the
more retransmission frames
as for SRP protocol moderate bandwidth
requirement is needed
with the completion of difference
between SRP protocol and go back in our
view protocol
the user datagram protocol commonly
known as UDP protocol is designed to be
unreliable and connectionless in nature
which applies process to process
communication model for data exchange
between devices and is activated the
transport layer of the OSI model
and is used to transfer data information
related to internet services over the
network channel where process to process
communication refers to the use of port
numbers in the header format during the
transmission of data over the network
channel
as for connectionless it means that the
UTP format does not provide established
path for the data to transfer instead it
uses multiple different paths which we
will look into further in the video
let's move on to the next heading
features of using user datagram protocol
the user datagram protocol provides the
network with various efficient and easy
to understand Network protocol features
to apply over the data that is to be
transmitted
where the first feature of UDP is
related to the working area that is the
UDP model is a transport layer protocol
of the OSI model and is used to deliver
best effort delivery options for the
data transmission where the best
delivery option refers that the protocol
does not provide the sender will receive
any acknowledgment from the receiver
site for the data transmitted or it
doesn't provide any guarantee of data
transmitted to the receiver site
now let's move on to the second feature
of user datagram protocol
the second feature represents the mode
of delivery or connection that the UDP
establishes for data transmission
the UDP protocol as we know already
establishes
a connectionless path that means there
is no actual virtual path for the data
to be transmitted
so that the each data from the UDP
format uses a random path available in
the network channel and reaches its
destination
now let's move on to the next heading
that is UDP header format
the UDP header format comprises of two
parts
first the UDP header part which is 8
bytes in size and second the data to be
transmitted
furthermore the header part is divided
into four different parts
Source Port destination Port total
length and checksum
where each of the parts are divided into
16 bits
let's take a look at the different parts
of the header format in a little detail
the first one is Source port number it
is a 16-bit value that is used to
identify the port that is transmitting
the data
next is destination port number
that is used to identify the port number
that will be receiving the data on the
receiver end
next we have total length as the name
suggests this value is used to specify
the total length of the UDP packet
including the UDP header part
and the last is checksum this is a
16-bit value field and is used as an
optional attribute
it is left empty if there is no need or
it is used in case where accuracy of the
data is to be measured
now let's move on to the working of the
UDP protocol
to begin with we have data from the
sender site
which is enclosed with a UDP header for
communication and data in the UTP header
part
the next step is to hand over this data
over to the IP section
for encapitalization
with the IP header and data with the UDP
header and data part
as for the last step this part is handed
over to the frame section where it is
transformed with the frame header and
data format
moving on now let's transmit the data
over the network channel for the
receiver and to receive it
over to the receiver side first step is
decoding of frame header part and data
part into the IP section which contains
IP header and data section
again this eyepiece packet is divided
into UDP header part and data part
from where the message is retrieved from
the data section of the UTP header
format and is then received by the
receiver end
now let's move on to the applications of
UTP protocol
let's take a look at some of the
features of the UDP protocol that
provides applications to various Network
models
for the first one we have it provides
flow control and error control mechanism
to the network model such as tftp
next it provides faster transmission of
data as there is no pre-established
virtual path needed
so it is used for real-time Services
live communication and gaming services
now let's move on to the last setting
for this session that is UDP versus TCP
protocol
we will differentiate between UDP and
TCP based on some attributes that are
mostly used in the network module and
the first attribute is reliability
for UDP protocol as we already know now
it is an unreliable in nature
that it doesn't provide any guarantee of
data transmitted to the destination site
is reached or not
as or TCP it provides reliable and
guaranteed data delivery to the receiver
site
the next attribute is acknowledgment
signal
the UDP protocol does not provide any
acknowledgment from the receiver site to
the sender site
whereas in case of TCP protocol sharing
the acknowledgment signal is very
important if the acknowledgment signal
is not shared by the receiver side to
the center side the data exchange will
halt
let's move on to the next attribute that
is connection mode
as we already know now
UDP is a connectionless mode of service
there is no virtual path established for
the data transmission to takes place
whereas for TCP protocol it is a
connection oriented protocol that is a
virtual path is needed for the data to
be transmitted over to the receiver site
or the destination node
the next attribute is error check system
in GDP protocol basic check system is
only used for error check
whereas for tcv protocol it is an
extensive error check service
and along with error flow control
mechanism included in the TCP protocol
service
let's take a look at today's agenda
firstly we will understand what exactly
the DHCP protocol is
then the allocation methods in DHCP
protocol
next we will understand some helpful
DHCP settings and lastly stepwise we
will understand the operation model for
DHCP
let's understand the DHCP protocol
the dynamic host protocol or DHCP is it
protocol that is designed to assign the
IP address to a device for it to access
the internet
this network model is based on the
client server architecture and removes
the process of manually assigning an IP
address to the system
now let's take a look at the allocation
methods for the DHCP protocol
the allocation method of DHCP is divided
into two types
the first type is the manual allocation
which as the name suggests is it a
signing of IP address to the system
manually by the user
the second method is dynamic allocation
which uses a client server architecture
to assign an IP address to the system
now let's see some points regarding the
allocation method
the first type is the manual location
as mentioned in this allocation type the
user manually assigns CIP address to the
system for accessing the internet and
can be observed in this instance
this is done by accessing the network
configuration setting off the device and
also requires other related
configuration such as
subnet mask preferred DNS server and
default gateway
let's now take a look at the dynamic
allocation
in this allocation method the client
device receives all the relevant Network
configurations from the DHCP server and
the system gets configured to access the
internet
the provided IP address is given for a
certain period which is also termed as
the lease
now that we somewhat understand what
exactly the dynamic allocation in DHCP
server is let's take a look at a small
example
open the start menu and type command
prompt
when the windows open up
type
IP
config
slash
command
as we see by this command we can take a
look at the network settings for our
system
over here we can see that DHCP is
enabled that means the configuration
that has been used on the system refers
to the DHCP server
and on the bottom side we can take a
look at the different network settings
that are given along with the IP address
by the
DHCP server that is subnet mask
default gateway
and the DNS server
now let's continue with the video
now let's take a look at some of the
notable DHCP settings
the first one is known as scope as the
name suggests a scope refers to a range
of addresses that are available to a
DHCP server for allocation of the client
device
next we have is lease this setting of
The DHCP server is designed to prevent
the holding of IP addresses by a single
device
this is done by assigning an expiration
date to the least IP address so that the
DHCP server has a minimum addresses left
for the client device
and lastly we have address reservation
in this DHCP setting the client device
requests the server to assign the same
IP address to the device each time the
address allocation takes place
this is done by identifying the MAC
address of the client device
now let's take a look at the operation
model for DHCP protocol
the DHCP operations are performed on the
user datagram protocol in short UDP
which is applied on two ports under UDP
which are Port 67 and 68.
the first phase is where the client
broadcast a DHCP server message over the
network to connect with the DHCP server
this message basically means that it
wants to connect to the internet through
the DHCP server
the second phase is when the DHCP server
receives the DHCP message
according to the message the DHCP server
reserves an IP address for the client
and network configuration information
including subnet mask default gateway
and preferred DNS server
in the third phase the client responds
to the DHCP servers offer through a DHCP
request message requesting the offer IP
address and relevant network
configuration for the system
then in the last phase the server
acknowledges the request broadcast from
the client and sends the DHCP packet to
the DHCP client which is comprised of
network configuration for the client
device to begin practicing the commands
we need to access the command prompt
application using the CMD command in the
start menu now let's begin with the list
of commands the first command is
ipconfig
this command displays the system's basic
IP address configuration data which
includes Network information about IP
addresses subnet masks and default
gateway
similarly we also have ipconfig slash
all command which displays all the
details regarding our device like Lan
settings physical address of the system
IP addresses subnet masks and DHCP
information
let's use the CLS command to clear the
application window for the next one the
next command is hostname which is used
to access the system's hostname
to verify this let's use the ipconfig
slash all command to check the hostname
in the information and for sure we have
the same hostname
let's perform the CLS command again and
perform the next command
the Ping command is used to check the
communication availability of the
destination host and the user system
for example use a ping command with
google.com to check the server
availability which gives us the
following result
also using the results IP address and
then the pin command we can get the same
result in case we just don't have the
domain name
we perform the CLS command again and
move on to the next one the nslookup
command is used to troubleshoot network
connectivity and find the IP address of
a domain like Google and Amazon as
applied just now to receive the name and
address of the domain
also using the MS lookup command and
then applying the server command with an
IP address we can get the domain name
belonging to the IP address
and similarly to check the number of
servers with the same domain name we can
do this and we have four name servers
for Google
we perform the CLS command again and
move on to the next one
the tracered command is used to
troubleshoot the routing issues of the
network by displaying the routing table
through which the data is transmitted to
a maximum of 30 hops in the network as
you can see
similarly you can also try amazon.com
and share your views in the comment
section below
now let's clear the application window
and perform the next command which is
the ARP command this command is applied
to display the communication exchange
between the IP address and the systems
Mac or physical address
let's move on to the next command which
is the path ping command
this combines the Tracer and ping
commands and displays detailed
information as an output for a maximum
of 30 hops in the network
this command takes some time to compile
the full hop details so that you can
share findings in the comment section
next we have the netstat command it's
used to display the network connection
summary of the system as shown in the
demo
similarly if we use the netstat hyphen n
command it will give us much more
details about the connection and UDP
details
next we have the net share command which
displays the details of where the data
resources for a system are shared and we
can check them under the share name
resources and remark column
then we have the route command that
allows us to access the routing tables
and also allows us to make changes to
them
let's try the route print command and we
have the interface list ipv4 routing
table details with all the active routes
and the IPv6 routing table moving on
let's clear the window and look at the
net sh command the netsh is a popular
command which allows us to view and
configure the network adapters in the
system
under the net sh command we have
multiple functions for configuring
settings let's try the show command and
we have the following result
moving on we have the task list command
that lists all the currently working
applications on the system with task or
program ID and the memory it uses let's
perform an example
access Google Chrome and then perform
the task list command and as expected we
have the Chrome details in the list
and if we close the Chrome window and
again use the task list command we don't
have the application active
similarly we also have the task kill
command which will terminate the task
corresponding to the given program ID in
the command window
for example let's access Chrome and
perform the task list command to check
the program ID
and then we'll use it with the task kill
command and we can see that the
application is terminated
to check our result we can access the
task list command again next on the list
we have the system info command
it's used to view all the information
about the system from the windows
version to the BIOS and booting
configuration
we can access all these details using
the system info command and the last
Network command for this session is the
wmic command
for getting detailed information on the
ports and functions of the system like
CPU details and then similarly we can
check the bio settings
let's start off with question one what
is the OSI model explain the different
layers of the OSI model OSI largely is a
theoretical model uh utilized to
understand networking and how data
packets are created and how they are
being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the TCP the
transmission control protocol over
Internet Protocol software suite
so OSI is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand they are as follows
so in this diagram there are these seven
different layers we start up from the
bottom first is the physical layer the
data link layer Network layer transport
layer session layer presentation and
application
when such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identify these seven layers explaining
what the OSI model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after this basic question
so let's start off with the physical
layer this is the lowest layer of the
OSI model now this is where any and
every physicality of your computer comes
into the picture so it could be an uh
network interface card it could be an
RJ45 or a CAT5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link layer
so on the data link layer as far as
networking is concerned we just need to
understand that data packet is encoded
decoded into bits at this layer this is
also the layer that deals with Mac
addressing so the physical address of
every network interface card which is
the MAC address which is utilized to
Route data package over the network this
is where the MAC address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer here
datagrams are transferred from one to
another the function of this layer on
routing and logical addressing the
moment we talk about routing and logical
addressing IP addresses come into the
picture IP version 4 IP version 6. so
Network layer will deal with IP
addressing and the routing of those
packets then comes the transport layer
this is the layer responsible for
end-to-end connections that
automatically signifies that this is
where TCP and uep will be working
TCP stands for transmission control
protocol UDP for user datagram protocol
TCP
is a connection oriented protocol
whereas UDP is a connectionless protocol
these two Protocols are utilized to
establish connectivity between two
machines
TCP is a more reliable method of
connectivity because there are a lot of
packets that are sent across to verify
that the data has been sent data has
been received and so on so forth whereas
UDP is a connection less protocol medata
is just dumped without verifying whether
the receiver
actually receives that data or not
so in a nutshell on the transport layer
TCP and UDP make their appearance and
this is where that functionality lies
then comes the session layer this
control signals between the computer it
establish maintains and terminates
connections between processes so in the
transport layer we talked about TCP and
UDP UDP being a connection less protocol
where data is just transmitted without
verifying whether the receiver received
that data or not whereas TCP we studied
is more of a reliable protocol thus
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly and then the next uh
segment of that data is being sent so
those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of TCP the acknowledgment
packets and
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session layer of
the OSI model
then comes the presentation layer the
presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mine or encoding that is being utilized
the utf-8 character set that we utilize
for presentation encryption mechanisms
all of these work on the presentation
layer
and finally comes the application layer
where
the application itself uses a particular
protocol
so that the other machine on the
receiving end
the application on that machine would be
able to understand what the
communication was about
right so in a nutshell
if I start from up top the application
layer will deal with any of the data
that the application
is generating so maybe an user input
you're logging in you're typing a
username password all that data will be
constructed let's say to an HTTP or an
https format that's where your
application layer comes in the picture
then the formatting of which into utf-8
and the encryption of which would be
done at the presentation layer then this
transport layer and the session layer
would kick in to establish a TCP session
do the three-way handshake establish
that connectivity IP addressing would be
done on the network layer Mac addressing
would be done on the data link layer and
when everything is ready on the physical
layer the packet will be sent out at the
receiving end the packet will be
received on the physical layer and then
all these layers will be reversed and
finally at the application layer the
data would be presented to the
application who would then execute it
and showcase it on the screen of the
recipient
so this is the way you want to explain
this question you want to be very
concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete earlier with the layers you just
want to give the basic functionality you
want to demonstrate that you understand
what the OSI layer is how the computer
functions and you want to move on from
there if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is Define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again most of your interview
questions are designed that way it's
basically to understand how much
conceptually you are aware about these
Technologies so you have to be reconcise
don't go uh rattling about technology
too much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is so when
data is being transmitted over a network
it can be transmitted either in one of
these particular manners it can either
be a unicast multicast or a broadcast so
what is unicost
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user to a single ratio so one to
one right so uh one machine talking to
another machine and nobody else so also
known as point-to-point Communications
1.1 the point if you have to send
information to multiple receivers then
you will have to send it using multicast
right so this is where your multicast
networking comes into the picture so in
our case let's assume it's a network
where there are there's a Class C
Network approximately 255 odd machines
and Within These there are two machines
that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point to point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place
if one machine wants to up to multiple
machines then the multicast comes into
the picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one or more or more sources to multiple
destinations multicast uses the internet
group management protocol also known as
the igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines are
subscribed to those particular groups
and whenever a message needs to be sent
through those groups
it will be identified by the igmp
protocol and then that particular
message will be sent to those multiple
machines that are members of those
particular groups
and then comes the broadcast the third
method is known as the broadcast as it
says it is going to broadcast to all so
this is one to all that is communication
between a single user and it is going to
be sent to all the machines in that
particular Network
right so the three ways unicast is one
to one
multicast is one to many
and broadcast is one to all then
question number three
what is DNS
DNS stands for domain name system it is
like the internet's phone book that is
responsible for mapping the domain name
into its corresponding IP address and
let me give you an example over here
wherever we go and open up let's say a
browser a Google Chrome browser we type
in
www.google.com and then we press enter
and magically Google comes in front of
us the website rather
now how does the computer know who
Google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand Google and
words like that computers don't
computers deal with binary zeros and
ones right and as far as Internet is
concerned they will only deal with IP
addresses and Mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in in the browser window in the
address bar google.com and press enter a
DNS query is generated automatically by
the browser where a packet is sent to
our DNS servers asking what the IP
address is so in short DNS resolves
domain names to their corresponding IP
addresses
there is a DNS server which will have
this index a database of all the domains
associated with their IP addresses if
one particular DNS server does not have
that information that you're looking for
it may query another DNS server who may
have that particular response so the
first thing is when you type in domain
name it gets resolved with the DNS it
identifies the IP address corresponding
to that particular domain name and thus
allows the computer to route that packet
to the particular
server where that domain name resides
so in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local PC you have typed in
cybersecurity.com there's a DNS
resolution that a query that goes to the
DNS server what is the IP of
cybersecurity.com the DNS server looks
it up in its particular database if it
has the corresponding IP address it will
then respond back the IP address is
172.17.252.1 after which the packet is
sent off to cybersecurity.com moving on
to question number four what is a
firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that I've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of firewall
that is what how you can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for right so firewall is either
a hardware or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or this allow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done based on the rules that
you have created on the firewall it will
then based on those rules identify
whether some traffic is allowed in that
Network or some traffic is to be blocked
from entering that Network so as the
screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic and not
allow that connection from happening in
the first place now there are a few
common types of firewalls that also need
to be included in the answer to this
question and the first one is a packet
filtering firewall these are the most
common types that you will come across
which analyze packets and lets them pass
through only if they match an
established security rule set now here
people do get confused when we say that
we analyze packets people think that
these firewalls will analyze the
contents of that packet which is not
correct
when the definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of deep packet
inspection or a DPI as it is known if
that capability comes into the picture
you're basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or intrusion prevention
system in today's world called as a
next-gen firewall okay so packet
filtering firewall essentially will only
analyze data package for its source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there on the firewall and
based on those rules it will either
allow that collection to happen or
disallow that connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter Network traffic
at the application Level So when you say
application Level they work at the layer
7 of The OSI model package filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
did work on IP addressing and port
numbers will work on the network layer
of the OSI model also on the transport
layer because you also look at protocols
proxy firewalls will work at layer 7
which is this application layer of the
OSI model and will deal with application
Level protocols such as HTTP https FTP
SMTP and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall these
filter packets are the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do the job of the first and the second
type of firewalls
the packets are compared to known
trusted packets but now the first
question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type 1 and type 2 firewalls like
packet filtering and proxy firewalls
that is because that is how the
firewalls have evolved we started off
with a packet filtering then we added
functionality to it and so on so forth
so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall is to allow
good traffic and disallow bad traffic
based on the rules that have been
configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multi layer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a VPN
VPN is also called a virtual private
Network it is a connection between a VPN
server and a VPN client
so it basically creates a encrypted
tunnel between the client and the VPN
server which is then utilized to secure
the connections that you are making with
the internet so as you can see in the
diagram
the user has a VPN client installed on
their machine the VPN client then
creates an encrypted tunnel to the VPN
server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can receive can
be received backed by the VPN server the
VPN server will encrypt the data back
and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to
eavesdrop on the communication mechanism
they will not be able to do so because
of the encrypted tunnel it is very
difficult to decrypt this or hack
through this encrypted tunnel it it is
possible but it is very difficult to
achieve that moving on to question
number six what are the advantages of
distributed processing now before we go
into advantages of distributed
processing we first have to understand
what is distributed processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems that use more than one
processor to run an application
here multiple computers across different
locations share the same processor the
advantages of Distributing processes are
as follows but before we go into the
advantages distributed computing is
basically where multiple machines will
pool their resources together to run a
singular application so an application
that has multiple resources and you can
scale up and scale down as and when
required the advantages are that it can
be very very useful in data recovery
for example read where your striping
data on various hard disks it is
reliable it is cheaper lower cost can be
achieved and it is easy to expand
because of the scalability factor that
we just talked about if there is loss of
data in one computer it can then be
recovered by another interconnected
computer and one of the examples would
be blockchain in today's world right
what is blockchain that this data is
created live and stored on a connection
of computer so if one of the computers
goes offline the other computers in that
network will still have that data and
there the blockchain will still function
without any issues the second point a
glitch in one machine does not affect
the processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
Mainframe machine so instead of having a
server bank I can have multiple machines
connect interconnected together and they
can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing mechanics so
depending on the amount of data
processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is tcpip
tcpip or transmission control protocol
over Internet Protocol is a set of
communication protocols that are used to
interconnect networking devices on the
internet this protocol defines how data
should be transmitted over the Internet
by providing end-to-end Communications
so essentially if you want networking to
be established on your machine you will
need tcpid
without TCP IP there will be no work
groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a toss tcpip is a software that once
installed on your machine will then
interact with the hardware which is your
network interface cards and then your
switches wires cables and all those
through protocols that have been already
pre-configured in it So within the TCP
Suite of softwares you will have all the
protocols all the functionality of the
OSI layer and each and every protocol
that works on each and every layer will
be predefined and pre-configured to work
in a particular manner the Internet
Protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the TCP
you are talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the IP will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient
so a TCP model is the compressed version
of The OSI the seven layers will get
converted into four layers the network
access layer internet layer transport
layer and application layer going on to
question 8
what do you mean by ipconfig and if
config both of these are commands the
first one on a Windows machine the
second one on a Linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the Internet
Protocol configuration this is a command
that is used on the command line
interface of Microsoft Windows to view
all the adapters and the configuration
of each and every adapters for their
network interfaces so as you can see on
the right hand side in the command
prompt screen if once you type in the IP
config command on the C prompt and press
enter it will give you a list of all the
adapters that are there
so you can see wireless LAN adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist at the
bottom you will see the Wi-Fi connection
wireless LAN adapter and it can give you
the IP version 6 IP address IP version 4
address the subnet mask and the default
gateway so this is the configuration
that allows the machine to know on what
network it is on what is the default
gateway for communicating to the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may exist in that
particular Network and what is the IP
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well ifconfig is the same
thing on the Linux Mac or Unix operating
system
so the command will also give you the
list of interfaces and the configuration
of each and every interface
it is used to configure control the
tcpip network interface parameters from
the command line interface
it allows you to see the IP address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see the
wlp 19s
the IP address being 192.168 43.215
subnet mask mean
255.255.255.0 with the broadcast being
192.168.43.255. question 9. what is the
difference between a domain and a work
group this can be a very interesting
question and can be a very lengthy
question at the same time a work group
is nothing but a decentralized network
where you have interconnected multiple
machines together and each machine acts
in its own individual capacity
things of itself as a server right so a
decentralized network you every user
manages the resources individually on
their PC so local users on their own PCS
managing the network shares what can be
shared from that particular machine what
data should be shared should not be
shared to whom it can be shared with and
so on so forth
it is good if you got a small Network a
few machines all together uh and you
want them to interact with minimal
management effort right so each computer
each user will decide what they want to
allow other users to see on that
particular Network and all of them would
be connected over a land a local area
network either a wireless or a wired one
so if you look at your home Wi-Fi right
now that is one of the best examples of
having a work group
the domain on the other hand is a
centralized Network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you've got a domain-based
username and password which when entered
onto a particular machine gives you
access to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you that is where the
domain comes in so it it also uses a
single sign on mechanism for all the
resources that are that are to be made
Available to You whereas in a work group
your local user only meant for that
particular computer right so coming back
to the domain it is an administrator who
is going to manage the entire domain and
all of the resources connected to the
domain the resources could be switches
routers servers data stores applications
web servers Mail Exchange servers and so
on so forth so all of these are
administered by an administrator through
the domain it is the most reliable and
Optimum solution for a large Network
where multiple users are going to
interconnect and share that data amongst
each other
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a VPN you can connect to your corporate
Network authenticated and get access to
whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that Network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another Wi-Fi you will lose access to
your previous Wi-Fi then the last
question for the networking section what
is data encapsulation in networking data
encapsulation refers to the process of
adding headers and trailers to the data
the data link layer binds each packet
into a frame that contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer will have a header and
a trailer that will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent so the hardware
address which is the MAC address comes
into the picture and gets added to the
header and the IP addresses port numbers
and all of those things would then be
added to this uh Traders as well so that
the data can be then routed to the
intended recipient of that particular
communication and that's a wrap on a
networking crash course we hope you
found this video informative and that it
helped domestify the world of networking
for you remember networking is a vital
skill in today's interconnected world
and with the foundation you have built
here you are on your way to networking
success if you enjoyed this crash course
and want to see more content like this
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and ring the notification Bell so
you never miss any update from our
Channel feel free to leave your
questions and comments down below we are
here to help you on your Learning
Journey so don't hesitate to reach out
thanks for joining us today and remember
the world of networking is vast and ever
revolving so keep exploring keep
learning and keep networking until next
time stay safe and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you